okay
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel welcome to
episode 7 of the pregame
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos um and
guys you already know the deal if you
have watched two or more of my live
streams and you do not subscribe me and
you we have
beef okay beef people
um before i start today's sponsor is
cooking with chris so this is a meal
plan that's actually got me down
maybe like seven eight pounds in two and
a half weeks so it's like basically you
send in your information to him and tell
him what foods you like and he makes you
like a custom meal plan so the link to
that is in the description and if you
buy one it supports the channel and
helps me get new equipment and new
cameras so you guys should think about
it
okay so today's topic is born again
virgins and does the church keep women
single but before we start i'm going to
have everyone go around say your name
your relationship status and
how old you are
my name is sarah garvey um
my relationship status is single
and what's the other one
how old you are i'm 40 years old
what i look like
and put and put in your your channel
oh yeah my channel is sara garvey s a
space r a garvey g r v e y
um and that's across all social medias
hey team uh my name is kit i am 27 years
old i am currently single
um i'm an actor by day youtuber by night
and youtube channel is stay slick with
kit that's me
hi guys my name is rhys i'm 22 and
i'm single currently
yeah you have a channel now don't you i
do but it hasn't started oh okay okay so
next stream
okay so i wanted to start by asking how
many of you guys grew up in the church
yep
yeah i did i grew up in a church in the
seventh-day adventist church
okay
yeah what's that it's like seven-day
event it's like uh
um
we worship on days on saturdays instead
of sundays
oh so it's like yeah
it's like a it's church but
the sabbath is different the sabbath is
more like the jewish sabbath because
jewish sabbath is on friday it's
saturday
so our sabbath was also friday to
saturday and not sunday
so
yeah my saturdays were spent going to
church okay what did you do on sunday um
whatever we wanted like for the rest of
the week we could do whatever but it was
very strict it was like
um friday uh sunset yeah everything just
you couldn't watch tv you couldn't
socialize you had to socialize your
family you had to like
um
read your bible they were like classes
wow yeah that's like pretty intense yeah
and then like saturday was church
and then we have to wait till sunset
again
and then
we're back to normal
did you
i went to catholic school okay
yeah so catholic church this is a church
table yeah wait so what do you what
about you guys christian
yeah yeah
yeah christian so i went to i went to a
church of england school growing up and
yeah
you know in church every sunday with the
fam so
so did you in your churches did you find
a lot of single women
like was it because for us it was like
probably three girls to every one guy
yeah i think um yeah there was a lot of
single women in the church and they
still are today
yeah you know they're still out today
yeah i felt a lot of the single women in
my church
were there weren't younger women they
were older women i found
um
yeah it's like they get to a point i
want to get right with god
after maybe
having a play
having a better life
which happens you know some you know can
happen different stages but
if we're talking about the women yeah i
actually think like
there's a difference in the way there's
a fundamental difference in the way
that men and women view god
and
that's why there's so many women in the
church this is my hypothesis right
so
women are attracted to powerful men
and god is the most powerful man
that's why you're here
that's interesting and that is why
you'll hear women say ah i don't need a
man i've got jesus
you've heard women i i've heard women
say that you know what and it's like i
don't i don't hear men say that men
don't say oh i'm i'm all right i don't
need a wife i've got jesus it's like
that's not
yeah but that's like that's my theory
like my theory is we have a fundamental
difference whether us consciously or
subconsciously in the way in which we
view god because god is the most
powerful man and women are attracted to
powerful men so here's my question
though so i'm attracted to jesus
i don't know i don't know the inner
workings of the psychology around it but
but so here's here's my question though
because is it that they're going to god
or is it that they're going to the
church
um i think a bit of both i think church
is like
it's a communal setting isn't it it's
like people
like to be around a certain community
yeah and i think it gives them that
sense of belonging to a community of
some kind but i do think
yeah i just think that it's different
and i also think like
see the last girl that i was seeing like
seriously
she was very heavily christian
and i'm not
anymore like i grew up but i'm really
not religious anymore and um
it was interesting because
when we were like together she was like
oh i don't know if this is correct i
don't know if this is right i think you
know
you should become a christian and i was
like no that's not gonna happen
um
she was like well i don't know if this
is right and i'm like
well look
we're in this we love each other like
what's the problem and she was like i
have to go and speak to my pastor right
and so i was just like okay
um
i'm not happy with that but if that's
what you feel like you need to do and
then she came back and she was like yeah
i don't think we can be together
and i was like isn't that interesting i
said yup that's a deposit must be your
man then
she was like what do you mean i said
because any man that can talk to you and
tell you not to beat me must be a man
i'm clearly not him
do you know what i mean so i said go be
your man and she was like
oh it's not like that i said listen no
no no no no because if i went away and i
said oh i'm gonna go and talk to
serena yeah and i came back from talking
to serena and i was at babe i don't
think we could be together
and a lot of women like they idolize the
pastors in these churches you know what
i mean like
they idolize the pastors so the pastors
have so much power like he's the closest
one to god of everyone right exactly do
you think that's why i think it's
completely different man i'll be honest
i think it's more
i think
i think a big reason why pastors today
are idolized a lot
by
single women is because
he tells them that god is going to bring
them my husband
so all they have to do is wait
and if anybody knows anything about life
you can't just sit in your ass waiting
for things to come to you right so it
kind of removes the responsibility
of having to
uh either put yourself out there or make
the effort or put yourself in an
environment
where
someone can come to you
right
and i also think part of the reason like
i said about
about uh you know
i like the internet i like the idea of
god's the most powerful man you know
um but again i think it's more because
i just know a few older women who use
the whole oh but i've got jesus as
as an excuse not to feel
lonely yeah
it's like you know if all their friends
have kids and they're married and stuff
and then she's the only one single just
like oh like what's happened she's like
nah i've got jesus right
and the thing is because it's like a
religious sentiment it's hard for
anybody like jesus ain't hugging you at
nighttime you're not going to argue with
that yeah
do you know what i mean but that's just
my thoughts don't you think it's them
arguing with themselves
yeah low key it's like
they they say not about jesus but just i
feel like they're thrown at you as you
said because they know it's a sensitive
thing yeah they're not they just throw
it so
other people can't be like to them all
yeah because you can have jesus and have
a man
because you can you can have both you
can but so
exactly that's that's really my point
yeah that's really my point but the
church sorry
i was gonna ask you the girl that like
broke it off with you because you
weren't christian were you hooking up
with her
yeah to some degree yeah yeah so like
isn't that
like she go ask her pastor about that
i mean
but that was that was
the point of contention yeah yeah that
she like how old was she she's like 30
33 oh gosh yeah
so it's like
that was a point of contention because
she felt guilty about it do you know
what i mean and i'm like
i feel guilty that very love
do we want do you know what i mean
but um yeah it was she had a stronger
sense
i guess or a stronger feeling towards
you know the church and her religion and
stuff which is you know it's cool it's
just like a very interesting experience
for me to go through like oh [ __ ] like
jesus cop blocked me do you know what i
mean
oh or you saved you oh you said you
never know you never know it's true you
never know you never know it wasn't my
it was not my portion
have you guys found do you think dating
girls in the church is better
uh like have you do you prefer girls
that are in church
i depend i
i think it depends what you're looking
for
okay i
i think because i've dated a couple of
girls who were quite
uh heavily christian and they're very
traditional
which
brings a lot of things which are really
nice yeah i agree if you're at a certain
stage in your life where
you know
um i'm gonna say
they're
quite wifey material but if you're not
looking for a wife then it's not for you
um at that point in your life i would
say
at this point in time in these days and
times
generally churches
are no different from the streets
the same women that are in church on a
sunday we're just in the club on the
saturday
well that's why i was asking because i
was thinking i've heard a common
complaint from men about dating in the
church is that they're for the streets
too and they thought they're going to go
to church to find a wife and they just
find like
a 304 in sheep's clothing you know like
yeah that's true no as i'm saying
there's a say i think that the women in
the church are the same nowadays to say
because the women that yeah they're in
the club they're in the bars
they're doing the same things that we're
doing but
i guess they have that in their head
they have that safety net of oh but i'm
going to church and you know i do all
this church stuff it's like well you did
have sex with tyrone last night forgive
me for that i'm saying
you didn't have sex with last night
let's not die but
if it makes you feel better that you go
in church on sunday then so be it do you
know what i mean so
i don't
you know when you say so you know you
said that you know some guy said about
the girls that go to church for the
streets are they
how old are these women they're younger
women are they older women like well
i've heard a couple different things um
i've heard a lot of like single ma
single mothers go to the church and they
become like born again virgins basically
i've in the church i was involved
[Music]
it's like when you re-virginize
do they do an operation to put your
hymen back or like
what's that
it's like um
i mean it doesn't really make sense
it's just basically like
where the girls
regret the guys they slept with before
and then they want to make the new guy
wait for marriage for the girl basically
um yeah and i've seen i've seen girls
that this like worked for actually like
like there were girls that um in my
church like from home i wouldn't say
they were like three of like super you
know but yeah but i've also seen girls
like still single in their like mid-30s
you know because they're waiting
and do you know what's so funny it's
very interesting you say that because
there's such a high concentration of
women in the church right
and there's not such a high
concentration of men in the church the
men that are in this church generally
are probably married
probably got probably got probably
really good men like probably good men
but so they get snapped up quite quick
by these women you know what i mean so
it's like
so then
what happens is it as i say in my
situation which is i've heard it a lot
of the time
um
the pastor will say obviously
the man is not in the church that you're
seeing because they have to go outside
of the church to get a man because
there's none in the church generally so
when you go outside that means you're
not getting a church guy
they tell the pastor and the pastor says
oh
he's not um of the same two people of
the same yoke or whatever the bible
verse is right you're not equally yoked
or whatever it was and so
the pastor
basically puts
you know a no and says no you can't do
that and it's like wow okay this is
imagine having like someone having that
much control over your life that
happened to me
that that with my last boyfriend like i
um because he wasn't because okay when i
when i got baptized they like told me
because i grew up catholic and then i
like switched to a christian church
right and um
but then like they have to have you
re-baptized even though i what i don't
know but
i was like they were born again
no well no i wasn't
no no but
i don't know that's not real like yeah
but my last boyfriend wasn't um part of
the church but it was like one girl to
every three guys so i'm like what the
what else am i gonna do
like i'm not trying to fight over the
like five beta guys here
that's amazing right
guys no they're they're soft they women
find church guys quite softly yeah
would you say that's true
yeah yeah yeah like they're quite square
and soft that's what i've heard women
say no okay this is usually how i'm
gonna i'm gonna tell you church dynamics
there's usually like one or two guys
that aren't like a couple right but all
the girls want him like i'm not trying
to fight over like over a guy with like
10 other girls that are all lined up you
know
yeah so
um and he knows he's got the pick of the
bunch yeah
like he's like whoa i could just swag
her into church
when i could just date someone not in
the church like that seems a lot easier
but then your pastor will say that's the
wrong thing to do that's well that was
the thing i got a call it was like
really awkward this was such an awkward
phone conversation it wasn't from the
pastors from like another girl that i
did like bible study with at the time
and she like called me and was just like
well
he
he's not in the church and i'm like okay
so so what like what are you telling me
to do should i dump him
but no i did it i just dated him anyway
but
oh there's that pressure though
no it made me not want to go anymore
yeah because it's like awkward yeah
you know
but that's the thing about this is the
difference catholics we mind our own
business okay christians are all up in
each other's business right because they
look at it as like a community thing the
catholics we would just get our
communion on sunday see no evil like
that
i'll leave it for confession
i'll go and tell you know i'd go and
tell the bishop or whatever yeah but um
yeah like
i think i feel like
church does keep women single like that
yeah when you can control
like
who you're seeing from who you're not
seeing even though knowing that there's
not a bunch of men in the church that
these women can actually choose from
like what's a woman supposed to do i
have a question
for the table
do you think
so these women who go to church and then
find jesus jesus later on in life
if they were already married and already
had the family unit that they wanted had
their husband that they wanted
do we think they would go back to the
church to be a born-again virgin
no
so ultimately they're going back to the
church because they want to find a man
or they might yeah they might think he's
there
that's what that's my point that's
interesting
help them
find or choose someone yeah because i
never hear married women being like i'm
a born-again virgin go right to the
church like it's it's never it's never
women who already have you know maybe
the the relationships that they want
yeah what do you think yeah no i don't
know i hear that well that's what rolo
tomasi talks about that that's a female
mating strategy
yeah because you get you get more um you
get more resources from the guy and
commitment
for when you give less
so that's that's like the hard time that
i kind of have with it because i'm
wondering i have friends that have done
it right they like i i don't think they
would have called themselves born again
virgin like that's kind of kind of
cheesy but they
yeah yeah like but they made the
decision like with their now husbands to
like wait right
but
it's almost like
i hope you feel a little salty if i was
a guy and i knew you were like nailing
all these guys for free and then i have
to marry you like
it's just i mean like
thing is i you know i'm you know i i
coach men and women i mainly coach women
in dating and stuff but
if you're looking for a relationship you
do want to wait to have sex like if you
sleep with a guy straight away
he's way less likely to take you
seriously but i agree like if you're a
guy and this girl is kind of
saying she wants to wait and stuff oh
that's really nice because you think
she's you know you have this and we have
this tendency to think you know women
are pure pure yeah they're not human
right yeah yeah and then you find out
that she had a trainer
but that's probably because she's taking
you seriously though
yo this is okay okay
maybe she's trying to tell me she's
taking me
i've had this before
i've heard of this before where if a
girl
thinks a guy's like if she's attracted
to a guy right
but she but personality she's like nah
he's not good for long term but i'm
really attracted to him she'll probably
have sex with him willy-nilly
but if there's a guy who she's attracted
to
and he has qualities that she's like wow
i think he'd be a great boyfriend then
she'll make him wait because she doesn't
want to [ __ ] her up is that true what
would you would you say i mean you're a
woman so you tell me
i'm really awkward i've never slept with
someone like right away like and i know
everyone always calls me cap on that but
um i would say with
[Music]
um
i don't know they call it and rolo
tomasi calls it like alpha and beta so
it's like there's like five guys that
girls are attracted to and i just
learned this so i'm probably gonna
butcher it but so it's like one is the
guy that's looks so that's like what
you're saying right like she'll just
sleep with him right away she's like
he's a bum he's good for nothing but
i'll just sleep with him
yeah because like god like he can't do
anything
then it's like the second one um is
what's the second one
um
the second one is like parental
investment so we'll meet you and think
like oh he would stick around and stay
with the kids and this is all like
biological so like the hot guy is like
the good genes right and the the they
call it like the beta i hate that for
yeah yeah and then there's like one
which i was told this is what like i'm
going for alpha fox bay or what beta
bugs you never heard that can i explain
it right now you've never heard of that
really no stop
money provisioning okay
sorry go on um so then this is the one i
was told that i look for the most
because torsh is the one you guys should
look at torsh's channel because she
explains this better than i can but she
said that this is what i always talk
about so it's like um legacy so it's
like a guy that one's like not going to
embarrass the family that's like um
i don't know that's like a hard worker
like that sort of thing like legacy
right um and then the next one is
parental investment money so it's like
income
and then i don't remember what the fifth
is
maybe someone in the chat is but i would
say like yeah if a girl
is just attracted like if they have
nothing else but looks then they'll
probably sleep with the guy sooner yeah
or if
i feel like if a girl knows that a guy
is like way out of her league like
she'll just like why wait
i i think that's true yeah i think
especially
one thing that i you know kind of i
coach my clients on
is that when a guy is just looking for
sex his standards are much lower
yeah they're much lower and if a girl
feels like oh i got the you know the
attention of this guy yeah stormzy yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean yeah yeah she's
like yeah of course straight away if i
can oh like the sexual attention versus
relationship attention yeah yeah
yeah yeah like that's
it's funny i've like rejected guys
because i felt like they were too good
looking
really yes
tell us the psychology behind that well
i'm like okay i'm really out of my
league no like that like i swear to god
you're like you're too hot no it was
funny because i found out this guy
wanted to date me later but i like i
figured he was just trying to sleep with
me because i was like what are you like
i just felt like he was out of my league
like
you're looking at me
yeah
no i swear to god because he was like
like really really like attractive and i
was like of course he just wants to
sleep with me but then i found out later
that he wanted to date me i was like oh
oh well
yeah that's going to decide messed up
yeah i know i i fumbled the bag but i'm
like
i don't know i don't think i'm the i
think most girls don't really understand
the difference to be honest yeah because
because they like the attention from a
man anyways what you're saying
so they don't understand whether it's
sexual or well it's kind of like when i
talk to girls and i'll see the guys
they reject and i'm like they're all
better looking than you
like i think this all the time brutal
honesty
yeah um why do you think
that uh
do you think it's always been like that
like women have always rejected guys who
you would say objectively were as
good-looking than them or no i think i
think birth control changed everything
because before okay before
if i slept with a guy like i had to
think about could i get pregnant right
and so
you know i think people were a little
bit more careful back then but you you
add birth control to the game it takes
away the consequence yeah so for
everyone right because guys would
probably think about it too they don't
want to knock up you know something ugly
so that gives like a smaller percentage
of guys access to like more women it's
very true
yeah it's very true i mean this that day
in app social media
like yeah we live in a you know
globalized dating market now yeah you
can link someone's from paris from luda
from dubai
so it just kind of
it's left a lot of men displaced i think
i forget you you coach women like do you
like do one-on-one sessions yeah i do
yeah so what are the biggest complaints
you hear the biggest complaints yeah
from women
um usually
usually why why do guys avoid commitment
or why do the guys they deal with yeah
why why are they avoiding commitment
from them basically
what would you say the reason that that
is
uh well i usually see how they dated the
guy and i'll be like okay well if you
started sleeping with him from day one
yeah you put yourself in the friends
with benefit zone which is kind of like
the friend zone yeah for guys it's
near impossible to get out of unless you
kind of distance distance yourself from
her or have some dramatic transformation
um but also like
if we're just going to keep it a stack
the kind of guys that you know
they're dealing with you know are the
guys who have options
do what i mean and if a guy has options
sexual options and if he's not looking
like you said to build a legacy or
settle down
then he's gonna play around it's like
well
he probably has a rota maybe three or
four different women right if one woman
is just like hey if you don't commit to
me today i'm leaving he's like bye so
don't you don't you think it's the
woman's fault then that what that for
not even realizing that in the first
place because if you know that he's got
this this rotation or if you even have a
feeling yeah then
you didn't go there with the right
foundation i think um i think it's both
i think
i'll be honest i think a lot of women
modern women today
they don't know how to date in a way
that leads to a relationship
because i think they've been told to act
like men which doesn't help them get
commitment a lot of do you think they
want a relationship
i think i think most yeah i think most
do i think you can go through phases
like you just want to have fun but i
think most most women definitely do want
to have a relationship i think if
a lot not all but if a lot of women are
honest with themselves they know they're
not wife material anyway
are you i don't think i'll be honest i
don't think
a lot of women think that
you don't think older women think that i
don't think a lot of i don't think a lot
of women look at themselves because
we're lied to all the time
like constantly yeah no girls are
because your girlfriend so you know
they will see you do you failed
relationship after failed relationship
after i know we're like no you just you
deserve it like you're doing great and
it's like
you know what she's doing is not great
no that's like
you know what your girlfriends is doing
is not great it's not leading to that
man yeah what she's doing is putting
herself in a certain bracket anyway and
then expecting to be all of a sudden be
someone's wife well and i also don't
think girls really date to get married
that's very true yeah they date for a
relationship right which
that's why that's what i remember date
do you think they really want it because
it's not really yeah so i mean by do you
think they really want it because it's
not really um
in terms of long term yeah because if
you're gonna go to date someone what is
it before
but then don't you think dating is is
changing now
like i just think
the relationships between men and women
are actually changing i think um
i don't think i was saying this on um
you know these emails yeah right i was
on her show and i was saying this on her
show and i said it to her i said i think
the model that we're working with yeah
ain't working
because the statistics are showing that
it's not working i think yeah go no no i
agree with you you know i'm just not
saying it's actually not working so the
next question becomes okay cool so
we're having all these failed
relationships both men and women yeah
what's the next step and i think the
next step is honesty
and you know what i mean and i think
we're just not honest like i said i said
when i was speaking to him i said a guy
knows
whether or not he's going to be
monogamous or not before he even gets
with you he knows himself yeah whether
he's going to cheat or if potentially
he's got that inaudible
women have been sold the dream of
monogamy but
sorry sorry so so if you've been sold
the dream of monogamy right yeah
he knows
he likes you
all right cool yeah yeah monogamous baby
yeah i love you too
and he knows people sign whole marriage
contracts knowing they're going to cheat
on their wife
that
every individual is capable of cheating
every individual yeah i know that but if
you know yourself and you know you're
the type of man or woman that your eyes
can stray right and yeah you might
yeah wouldn't you just be honest no
joe lie
okay and say because they want because
they feel like they found the man or
they found the woman they're not going
to tell the truth i i think girls i
think guys are more upfront than girls
give them credit for we just don't
listen yes so guys will say i'm not
looking for something serious and girls
will take that as let me sleep with him
until he changes his mind
we're talking about two different things
because some guys actually really just
ain't honest and then that's true some
girls really
don't listen
there's both of them dynamic that
happens that's true you know that's true
there and i've always said to people be
honest because when you're honest you'll
get your best outcome you know it might
take a while
but if i say to a woman you know what
you know what babe i love you you know
but or where to date and i'm like you
know what type of guy you know what type
of guy that i may want like two women or
maybe three oh oh my god no all right
peace not you
yeah but there will be a woman that'll
be like hmm
okay yeah but don't you think someone
likes to just hold on to girls just
because they can like because you you
know you know how you said peace not you
don't some man will be like hmm
stay here until i find the next one then
then i will let you monkey branches yeah
you know what i'm saying no that's true
i think both men and women do that as a
matter of fact i think there are women
out there like i don't know what
statistic was i it was on the view
actually the women were talking about it
and they were saying um
that a lot of women
have like a reserve guy
of course come on
men do too though men do too yeah no the
stat was on both ends it was like
it was women i don't remember off the
top of my head i'm gonna butcher it but
i know women it was more but like still
a decent percentage of men did too but
the thing is
and that's the thing why not just be
honest
well because why not say i want both of
those
i want both of you i want both of you
babies okay have you do you do you feel
like you're not monogamous
i feel like i can be monogamous my last
relationship was 10 years okay i was
together with a woman for 10 years i was
monogamous throughout the relationship
okay right so i know i can be okay what
i'm doing now honestly
is looking at the landscape because i'm
now single i'm like
is it is it
do i want to go back into one a
monogamous relationship or
do i want to try something different
okay i just wanted to know if you've
ever said that to a girl and how she
reacts 100 i've said it to a girl okay
what'd she say to all the girls that i
meet okay
really but like
as actors as artists
especially in my industry people are
more open-minded
okay yeah
yeah i could see that especially in
musical theater because that's what i do
so
yeah they can be a bit more not
everyone's like that but they can be
more open to it
okay so how
did any of them react poorly and just
say they could never do that yeah um
i don't they're like i don't share yeah
women have said that
they've said i don't so are you guys
both trying to set up like
like would it be like a three-way
relationship or would it be like
like involved too yeah yeah like is it
is it like
is it like the two girls with the one
guy you know and then they become like
sister girlfriends or whatever
like okay you're my you're my girl
and i will
i'm basically gonna go to the streets
and like f these girls i don't care
about but don't worry they're just like
hoes that one okay
i've had a conversation with a girl that
i've been involved before and you know
she's you know like you said you said
about being open and it'll be one of
those things where it's like okay so for
my press nights and premieres and stuff
you're
my
person
you're the person that you're my god
that everyone goes oh he's with her
but we can
do our thing
both of you can yeah i said i was open
to it we well we discussed about so
you'd be okay with your woman going out
and yeah
yeah you see here's a different
relationship i'd have i would have an
open relationship but i think if i was
gonna be honest if she was gonna for the
mother of my children probably not i'll
be honest
so sorry about my woman's not not taking
pipe from anywhere else
well you said she did you just didn't
know well that's what i'm saying
yeah if i don't know then fine yeah but
if i if i know if i'm gonna be i'm not
gonna be like oh yeah you can take pipe
from somewhere else baby
no i think if i was gonna take like to
take seriously seriously i don't know if
i'd do that but foot like i'm not
looking to get married and settle down
right now right no i get you i wouldn't
i would i would entertain that now yeah
yeah yeah
so then it wouldn't be a girl or just be
a as you said person it wouldn't
necessarily be your girl and that's why
i said relationships are changing yeah
because those types of relationships are
becoming more common nowadays but i
think ironically the way it's changing
is going back to how it used to be thank
you that's exactly what i said
that's exactly what i said because of
how it used to be prior to prior to
this is what there's a book called um
out um out of eden right so prior to
um
the western colonization of the world or
the western ideal of what a relationship
should be right
most
places on the planet had polygamous or
poliginous relationships that's true
most places as well so i think what it
was was the most capable powerful high
status men
would have kangaskhan a harem of women
but the thing is that this and i does
anyone know chris williamson have you
ever watched his
his channel he has really good chats and
there's something like i watched the
video of his a couple weeks ago that's
oh my gosh it's so true
having a
polygamous society is is incredibly
destabilizing because what ends up
happening which is happening now you get
the majority of men
who get
very little to zero attention
and there's nothing more dangerous than
a young aggressive man with nothing to
lose so that's what they call it incels
isn't it
facts
that's where this whole kind of
you know young men going up shooting up
places yeah themselves yeah
yeah no that's actually true no i agree
you know what's interesting i was just
thinking you're kind of like so you're
helping girls right yeah and guys as
well but yeah yeah yeah yeah but like
you also like are kind of the guy that
like
has the rotation right that's what you
said that's what you just said you
wanted like with the open relationship
okay
but i mean it's like but you know i
think
especially half half of the time when
i'm coaching you know my clients it's
kind of more i haven't like a very
honest honest policy so it's kind of
like you said that if i get involved
with a girl and if i'm at a stage where
i'm not looking for anything serious or
if i'm open to it whatever i'll be like
look this is where i'm at take it or
leave it and that's what i encourage
everyone to do
um
for
half of the things i say for my clients
is just telling them the truth that
society
is is truthing the lies that society has
told them so
you see you said this is who i am take
or leave it right because this is why i
look at the world
whether we want to like agree or not
yeah like
men and women
there's like an attractive scale in this
general society yeah you know people
will find kim kardashian somewhere only
a scale when people might find out no
a woman just off the street on the scale
right yeah so do you think now
i'm i'm not judging you but do you think
if you were fat
right yeah
and balding or something right that you
could tell a woman ah you know i'm going
to see a couple of women
like do you think that there's there's
pretty privilege and there's rich
privilege
right
yeah but what if you're a fat and broke
yeah
i could tell her but it doesn't mean
she'd accept it basically what you're
saying is would less women accept that
obviously yeah yeah that's the less
girls would give him a chance to begin
with
so those types of guys are
going back those types of guys are like
are becoming the incel guys yes do you
know what i mean and like what i've seen
in this quote-unquote red pool community
manosphere is a lot of angry [ __ ]
guys man like there's a lot of
all the time guys oh my gosh especially
in my comment yeah like respectfully
like feel free to you know send super
chats i love you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
it like took me for a surprise when i
first got onto the space because i was
like i was like being called ugly every
single day i was like god damn
honestly i think half of it is they're
angry at
themselves but it's more like of course
because they
many many because
they've been sold a lie we all have
like i think every i think any guy any
girl as well but mainly guy any guy who
gets to a point where
you know
he
can attract women realizes all this [ __ ]
he's been told when he's younger is
nonsense
about
having about what to do because a lot of
a lot what these guys do is they
basically simp for a girl they've been
told that symptom for her is going to
get her love
and that doesn't happen and then they
get angry at the girl it's like well
at some point but you know who told him
to do that
well yeah disney feminists
facts
that's true feminists told him to do
that that's true
they said listen be more in touch with
feminism
and films like all of that [ __ ] like be
the prince charming and he's like hang
on tyrone over there
yeah
just slid inside your vagina right and
he didn't have to do [ __ ]
but they lie to girls too they just lie
in a different way that's true so they
lie and tell you that like the guys that
you want are just going to like
magically pursue you and make you the
center of their world and all that stuff
will happen you know
but like the guys we want aren't going
to do that you know that's the irony
isn't it
someone who would actually do that for
you is not the person that you would
want no because i think that's awesome
but it's more because like usually the
guys that do that don't see really value
in themselves
that like simp super hard don't value
themselves because like i've had guys
like where
they're just so into me so fast and i'm
like what's wrong with you and i'm not
saying that to like put myself down but
i'm like you don't know me
like so
bro
oh my god
that comes down to that i'm looking for
something like let's say it's a it's a
um
a motherless son
yeah he might be looking for you to
replace his mum so that's why he he
might be
coming to you thinking oh she's going to
be the
my my my whole
she can feel my whole job he's going to
play the matriarch in my life exactly
yeah exactly yes exactly but then yeah
sorry so that makes that will make them
attract uh not even attracted to you
attached attached to you and then in
their head they're thinking okay
this is why i go this is what i gotta do
this is what i gotta do and this is what
i go do to make her happy
meanwhile he's not even making himself
happy or thinking about his own interest
you understand so i think
yeah there's i think that happens a lot
but
i think most guys are scared to even
unlock that side of their thoughts if
that makes sense yeah i'm saying so then
all of this starts to happen
and then the girls are like because they
will present someone they think
they want to be to the girl yeah and
then it might be something else and then
that's how it all break down yeah it
didn't start on a proper
foundation yeah make sense yeah yeah
people are lying man like i think people
are lying to themselves mostly yeah and
then they're lying to other people and
they're expecting
people to actually um understand them
and that's why i think like i said when
the whole this whole dating thing is
changing it's changing
because people are a little bit becoming
a little bit more honest now like the
podcast generation has arrived and
everyone's talking about it and becoming
a little bit more honest but
generally people i just really do think
that honesty is like the best policy and
it's like
as a man
you know like i said you know what you
want
tell them what you want as a woman
the thing is with a man i feel like in
these days and times men have more
realistic
wants than women do yep that's what i
generally would you agree with
me saying that women think short term
and men think long term is that like
kind of what you're saying as well
what do you mean
girls think oh
for now life if you
like in my
in my experience speaking when i speak
to girls and i'm like oh so what do you
see yourself bear in mind i'm 22. yeah
so like for me
when i'm asking girls my age okay cause
30 where do you think you are they're
just saying um
they're not thinking about yeah they're
not thinking about whatever yeah don't
get twisted that's not every girl it's
like that of course yeah but then you
ask a guy he's like yeah i'm trying to
one two three four five yeah understand
it out and he said yeah
because girls don't think so long term
yeah
they like they don't they're
more careless so what i would i i
i agree in that sense i would say that
i think a lot of girls if you ask them
you know if they're young you go oh
where do you want to be on your 30
relationship wise
i think a lot of them will be able to
tell you
whereas i think guys would be like oh if
i'm married by 30 yeah that's calm but
if i'm not then i'm not because a guy's
not making his focus the woman
yeah well yeah yeah the woman's making
her focus demand you know
and i think women are attracted to that
that's weird sometimes yeah is it i
think women are choosing that way guys
who
are more focused on themselves than
doing something or building something
yes oh there's nothing worse than a guy
that puts you on a pedestal because we
can't live up to it
like i've that's what i don't know what
like sometimes i'll
like i don't know sir there's a certain
type of guy that just like
when they meet me they just get like
they put me on this like pedestal and i
just can't like live up to it you know
what i mean
i don't know
but they're they're how what do you mean
what's happening yeah
um
uh it's just okay okay okay it's just
like
the last
um
there was a guy i dated and he just like
was so quick to like oh like i want to
get married at this time i want to do
this with you this is like like this is
like my timeline for everything and it
was like cool but i just felt like you
don't even know if i'm a wife yet
because you don't know me yeah right but
like i don't know i give off this vibe
where i think people like trust me very
soon
but i'm like why would you trust me this
soon you know what i mean that's
interesting it could be him to impress
you
true it could be i mean i like ended
that cause it was just too much but
that's a little pressure yeah
and but i think that's how guys feel a
lot of the time because the girl will be
like
i'm ready you know yeah yeah yeah girls
are like i want to do this i want to do
that i'm ready
but they have that biological clock
don't know that they've got tick in as
well yeah i can understand why they're
trying to
you know get things done in a certain
amount of time yeah i've definitely had
it i've had a few times where
like i started dating a girl and within
two weeks she was like so when are we
going to make it official and i was like
you've been on three dates
[Music]
like we've spent an accumulative
accumulatively amount of eight hours
together yeah like you don't even know
me that well oh actually question this
is going to be a good question because
i've asked this on different how long do
you think it's too long for a girl to
stay in the talking phase
oh what is the talking phase define like
like you're
um oh gosh because you can use it in so
many terms let's say sleeping with a guy
so you're sleeping with it yeah and then
what's coming out of that phase but like
when you say like who wants a
relationship
like how dating until it's too long ah
yeah pretty much
how long's a piece of string i would
honestly i would say
anything longer than four months is way
too long
if you're look if you're looking for a
relationship yeah
i'd say within four within three four
months a guy knows if he wants to be in
a relationship with you
and if you don't make him make a
decision
he won't make a decision
because if a guy can sleep with you and
other girls at the same time he's going
to do that i would have said three
months too so it's interesting we're at
the same time why did you come to three
months
um
i don't know it's just like what i've
seen
yeah like
um
i don't know i feel like if three months
you know a person yeah before that like
you could just be getting to know each
other but even if you go on like one or
two days a week like three months it's a
lot of time right that's true that's
true but i do think that people the
older they get kind of move quicker
depending on what they want yeah yeah
because they've got a lot less time for
the [ __ ] oh yeah i was just about to
say
they're more susceptible to telling the
truth like if i'm 40 if i'm when i'm
ready to get to a relationship i know
exactly what i want to do
yeah all right i'm wasting no time so
don't you think that comes down to most
people don't know themselves
it could be that it's a good point it
comes with age yeah yeah i won't lie
yeah like i said being in a relationship
for 10 years
that's not like these are experiences
asian experiences i feel like i feel
like it's more so experiences yeah
because that can mature you and your
experiences can mature you right that's
generally aged as well
sorry no i think um
i wish i think that like girls dating
with more of an age gap kind of helps
them because the guys are a little bit
ready to like commit faster you know i
agree but it's not really like pushed at
all like i never even thought about
dating older guys until i like found the
red pill to be honest
yeah because
they're kind of
aren't women attracted to older guys
generally though
i wasn't like
not really like
i it was kind of weird like before 24
i like could not even see a guy over 30
i was like they're like invisible but
then when you hit like 24 25 then old
guy you're like
our dad's hot now
i was like when did when did that happen
for me anyway but before that no i
didn't even but i think it's with a guy
who's older he has the option though
he has an option to date a woman his age
yes
and also a younger one yeah yeah
i mean i think women once they hit like
35 40
guys at 35 40 are looking to look
further down they're looking like 20s
guys that yeah yeah if they can
so i think like when a woman hits like
35 or 40 and stuff she needs to go and
look for like i don't know a 50 year old
you know guy or something i don't know
you know she starts messing around with
younger guys
and that's what the and and she's
literally those guys little like peace
yeah you know what i mean like you know
what's interesting how they have you
seen the delusion calculator for women
i've heard of it i haven't seen it no
is that when they put in all of yeah
requirements and it tells you what
percentage of guys are actually like
that yeah it's interesting because i did
that for men i found the male equivalent
but i did it with like girls in their
20s because i was like what percentage
of girls are actually in their 20s
oh yeah
what percent do you think of girls in
what in western
oh i think i don't know i'm guessing it
was the us i think but i actually don't
know what percentage of women are in
their 20s yeah i would say 15
it can't be that high if you if you
think people live until 80. um
i would say like 20 20 maybe yeah what
is it what do you think
i think like 30 40. what do you think 40
percent of the population of girls in
their time
of the population yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah around 15 to 20
what is it i i i think it was 13
actually 13 to 18 around there so you
were kind of right that makes sense it
was
um but then i was thinking about it you
can make it you can make any stat small
because if you add like then half of
girls in the u.s are overweight oh yeah
that's so true yeah and then you add if
you i don't know like you don't want a
feminist it's like smaller than yeah
yeah but the thing is that i've seen the
delusion calculator on the women's side
and a lot of the time it comes out like
that man doesn't even exist oh yeah for
sure
i mean like everybody who are you asking
for
this man
that's what i'm trying to say
you're asking for god or something like
this man doesn't exist well and the
crazy thing is because i grew up i'm
like my dad is the like i don't know the
high value guy that the girls were like
income wise right like he's in the top
like half a percent of earners in the
u.s
so i'm like y'all ladies could not
handle one of them because one
you think he's gonna pay attention to
you he works 80 hours a week
good luck like i'm like you always come
second my dad went to india for like a
month at a time to develop software
there and like start a business in india
right and it was like
so i'll hear these girls like talk about
what they want i'm like do you not think
you're gonna work yeah
like yeah do you not think you're gonna
do anything you think you're just gonna
say a lot of um what this is being said
like in the red bull community like
at quote unquote average women
are not looking for quote-unquote
average men okay no they're looking for
men above average oh yeah and so if
you're looking for a man above average
that above average man isn't necessarily
looking for your average ass what's
above average
i'm just like whatever
because just whatever you're using
whether it be looks more yeah yeah yeah
every like if you're average it's a
combo yeah i'm saying if you're average
why
are you not looking at your
your like thing is though i would i
would argue that
um
it's actually
women or females in general of a species
looking for the top dog is very normal
hypergamy is normal like if you look at
it yeah if you look at primates or the
lion kingdom they it's not nine
lionesses to nine male lions they choose
the top male lion and they all choose to
mate with him primates and alpha
gorillas that's the exact same thing so
whoever the top one is
the females instinctually are more
likely to choose i think the difference
is we we are more we're exposed to way
more people now but i don't think they
understand what it means to be with that
man
not today i mean i agree yeah they don't
understand what it means they think that
man is going to be the same prince
charming that they've created in their
head and is that no no he's gonna you're
not even going to see that dude
and he's going to expect you to work
you might have expected my she had
seven kids for him
and then she helped him build his
business and she quit teaching to do
what he wanted to do and lived where he
wanted to live it wasn't
like i think the women of this age
of this era
want that guy like your father exactly
but they want to be like some prissy
little
i don't know internet model or something
it's like yeah that guy's not gonna want
you parading yourself all over it all
over instagram my mom was on facebook
yeah she had a really lit facebook
actually we would always i would from a
young age on the facebook yeah
but it's also like it's also when you
talk about people who
um who are like in the top percentile of
earners
everybody thinks that they're just
sitting at their desk with their feet up
just watching the millions roll in and
that's not yet
well they're working 80 90 hours a week
six seven days a week 52 weeks yeah well
there's a cost to everything and people
think you can have the benefit without
the cost and that that's the problem
like
i
i didn't really know my dad that well
until i was older like like me i'm like
so close with him now
and but you know that was the cost was
he was gone a lot and then when i got
older you know now i can hang out with
him all i want because he's retired
but there's a cost to everything yeah
100 like and it's an and even a like
even a man like what i feel is that a
man can
if we go out and find if we go to the
shop
we go to tesco or i don't know and
there's a girl on a checkout yeah and
she looks cool
all right she's nice we'll go out on a
date with her yeah it doesn't matter if
you're a multi-millionaire or an average
guy well because
men value different things yes yeah like
you guys if she's hot enough yeah
but you're not getting you're the right
quality you're not gonna go to a up to a
300 pound girl and ask her out but a
girl might if he has enough money
yeah exactly i feel like there needs to
be a troll
there has to be an attraction there
first yeah before you can even yeah
fathom to go and speaking about anything
else yeah used to be anything else and i
i always say to guys like
why don't like
there are tens on instagram people are
called tens you know i mean like they're
in here like looks wise yeah and i just
said to guys like
they're not real though right but i said
also
i said but what qualities does she have
because
for me as i get older i admire
the qualities of a woman over
the fact that she's a 10. 100
that's something that girls don't
understand and this is something i
didn't understand like i was one of the
girls that didn't get it i didn't
realize how many guy like
men are attracted to like more girls
than i thought
like i feel like guys attraction floor
is like lower than i thought for some
guys there was no attraction flaw
no like whenever i i i would rate girls
like i'll talk about
like one to ten right and if i've ever
done it with a guy the guy always rates
the girl like higher than i would
oh really why do you think that is what
it looks ways yeah right
um why yeah
i don't know i just i think
[Laughter]
well you guys are attracted to them like
where i'm not
you know
so no i think i think
quote unquote average looking women
with good qualities as a wife girlfriend
or partner
i would take that over a 10 on instagram
who's just abs airhead
i think any day if a guy's looking for
something serious he will go down in
looks 100
to go up in
personality and that's qualities
cooperation
we don't because we always think it's
about looks yeah like naturally we
always think it's just it's not um yeah
and i think i think it's because of like
social media like even dating apps now
like that's
90 of it of your success rate is going
to be predicated on looks because that's
what people are seeing
instagram is all about what you're
showing like
so much of our attention currency is
based on looks
so everybody we all think about that oh
we think it's purely on looks but when
you get into real life it's there's more
than that have you ever been catfished
where a girl didn't look at all like her
profile yes yeah
why are you laughing
you got a story you just tell us the
story right now
you know do you not know this app called
um
no no okay well b-i-g-o b-i-g-o no it's
a live streaming
uh app and you live stream and you can
get these things called um
i think they're called coins
or gems or something and um
you basically get paid for just
um streaming basically okay that's what
biggo is but anyone could log on
um
you can you guys can make an account now
and there could be ones in america china
uk whatever free sponsor um
basically i was on there one day
and you can have private chats
i was on a one day and i had uh i went
into someone's room and they were
discussing i've got to discuss somebody
discussing something
and then there was this girl had a nice
um
uh
the
display picture was nice
yeah so uh sorry i um
i followed her and then she started
talking to me surprising yeah so she
started talking to me
and then she invited me to a private
chat
cool talking to her talking to her
talking to her she gave me a number
eventually had her number
and we're talking
and eventually just to cut a whole long
story eventually
she was like to me
that she's a he
oh mate oh
so oh so this whole time i'm talking
like i'm talking to
her
yeah
but was it sexual talk
oh
[Music]
a couple couple months later i get a
call from him
dad and listen i just had to just hang
up the phone how did you find out she
wasn't here because
like me like
jesus because i'm not really like
basically i'll get i'll just get bored
i'll do anything and i'll just i'm just
like
you're gone yeah yeah right and then
like if there's no like
yeah there's nothing keeping you there
mentally yeah yeah
i'm going um and then
it was just like
i don't know what to call him
yeah but uh she was just like oh why are
you airing me you're just hearing me did
it or whatever because i was aiming for
time and then
eventually that's when
he said oh yeah
i'm a i'm a boy
from the uk and it was scary because he
called me a month after man
and
yeah i just had to let him know nah
that's not here it's not it was not and
i told him as well it's not even a thing
because the first time he told me i was
like yeah bro nah and then you quote me
again i was thinking brother now you're
trying to take a piss because i've
already done told you like yeah yeah
yeah of course yeah man but yeah that's
my story that's why i laughed because
you always said catfish back yo no
um where like a couple of my friends if
they're on dating apps then they match
with this girl who's like sorry they
match with this girl who's like
a nine or a ten
and she starts speaking he's like my
gosh i matched this girl she started
speaking to me first i'm like
and then he checks the profile checks
the description
oh i'm
a man or i used to be a man whatever and
i'm like half the honestly i feel like
if it's a really really really
attractive girl
and she's initiating with you
i just always assumed that i'm like
something suspicious
i'm just something suspicious because
girls like that have so much dick thrown
at them yeah they don't change anything
yeah it's true yeah you'll be surprised
though cause it's like that's happened
to me before and i'm like that's what me
yeah yeah
hey listen
what's in the blue moon it all happened
like i'm about
a couple of do you do you know love
island
i
vaguely like i've heard of it oh okay
i've dated a couple of people from there
before but it's just and not that they
made a move but they made it very
obvious that they were into me and it's
just because i was their type
so like if you're all down to a if like
if you're a girl's type down to a t then
she might right then she might you know
i mean yeah but like oh
but yeah people ain't waiting around no
more yeah they see it they like it
they're going for it
um thank you somebody cash app to me
gold professor for contributing to the
studio fund thank you very much
um feel free to keep those rolling in
that's right
okay wait so question
if you guys are looking for like a wife
okay
um do you
would you guys want to date someone
who's a virgin
no
nope no it doesn't matter to me i'm not
gonna lie really yeah
it doesn't matter
not a one bit so isn't it
isn't it interesting how
they always talk about how men value
purity and i and i think they do like i
don't but like obviously no guy wants a
girl that's been ran through but every
time i ask guys if they want a virgin
they say no why is that remember when i
said last time when i said i said
there's there's this unattainable
yeah woman
there's this unattainable pure woman in
a man's head
do you want her to know what she's doing
yeah it's a contradiction yeah it
doesn't say it's a contradiction i want
to know what you that you know what
you're doing
have you ever slept with a virgin
once i was a virgin yeah i have yeah
yeah stayed away what
i think after that i
if a girl told me to remember you for
life was that yeah was that just a
one-time thing no that what that you had
sex with that virgin well we lost our
virginity together oh okay i don't know
yeah what size has it ever happened to
you guys where it's you guys have done
it once and you're still
with the same girl
[Music]
so my first relationship i
took her virginity but i had already had
sex before yeah we stayed together for
like six and a half years
okay yeah and then did the sex get
progressively better did she she started
doing things you're like wrong like
teach
yeah you had to teach yeah i had to
teach okay but did she not do anything
to surprise you
you know it was mostly on me yeah yeah
did you prefer that
no sometimes you want to be surprised i
guess you know what i mean like you want
to be like
okay cool so oh you're doing that but it
only gets to there once you start the
teaching process you know what i'm
saying that once you start the teaching
process then that they get confident
enough to do that because a lot of the
time virgins aren't that confident
actually do you know what i mean but you
do want like a sexually confident woman
but you also don't you see i said it's
unattainable but you also don't want a
whole
i i mean i had um
i have had a show
called who gets wifed up faster hoes or
prudes
fruits
it might be hoes you know is it hers
it might be hoes why
i think that
um some girls have like mastered the art
of making a guy fall in love because she
gets really good and like bad yep
and
but i also think if you do it like too
much
then you know then i don't know but from
what i've seen
i've seen hoes get wifed up faster yeah
i think it might be hard right because
they probably know how to go after what
they want i think it's experience
but i also think you guys like
prefer a girl that's like all in and the
hoes like what do they gotta lose
you know what i'm saying where the where
the prude will be like oh no
one month two months three months and
the guy's like f bad i'll just take the
girl who's gonna do it now honestly
speaking like if we lived in a society
that i think about if we lived in a
society where you know chastity was
actually like
um i don't know put on a pedestal
then
i'd want a virgin yeah but i'd want to
be a virgin myself yeah yeah i think i
mean so we can kind of explore that
together yeah
uh i think
i think the reason i would say no now
is because of the culture of sex that's
right yeah i think i think if you've
developed a certain
if you've had you've got a certain
sexual appetite
and you've you know had enough
experience that you know what you like
etc i think it's it's very difficult to
go
back
because i'll be honest there's just one
girl that i dated a few years ago
that in terms of
everything that she was on paper
was like great was the most like
everything was perfect on paper
but the sex was the worst i'd ever had
the worst and it was mainly because
and it was not any bad thing but like it
was mainly because
she'd only slept with one person before
me and she'd only been with him for a
few months
so
she wasn't that experienced
and i know for a fact i tell you if i
met her when i was a virgin we probably
married 100 yeah but it's because of
that experience of having developing a
sexual appetite and everything now i'm
like i can't chris rock said it best he
said women can't go backwards in
lifestyle and men can't go backwards
sexually
and i was like wait so what made it so
bad
uh wait like make it youtube friendly
what made it bad it just wasn't
i don't know
is it just like boring oh okay okay like
the rhythm was awkward yeah the rhythm
was awkward and like i think
you know i think
there wasn't a it felt like there wasn't
a lot of um
effort on her part okay that's what i've
heard
that's that's what i've heard it's not
her fault yeah she doesn't know any
different do you know that's what i've
heard from guys is it's like they can't
stand girls that are like lazy in bed
and just want to like do nothing yeah
that's what i always hear
there's nothing worse than a woman
that's like lazy i'll be honest
from my experience the most attractive
girls are the laziest in bed that's what
everyone says in the red pill yeah
really you know what do you know why
london because they have not
they don't have to work to get together
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying the
pretty privilege kicks in it's like well
i'm just pretty
come and get me and it's like oh yeah so
every guy she's been with
yeah she's trying to be put in the water
trying to put it on his bed
and she can't yeah she don't know what
you're doing all right what about would
you marry a virgin i mean would you oh
yeah i would yeah yeah but i value um
legacy yeah right but that's like big
for me but no i really wanted to wait
till i was married i wish i did but i
didn't
so would you so you wouldn't mind
so if you were at this point you've had
sexual experience and you found a guy
who was a virgin
would you mind like teaching him things
um
most guys have to teach guys anyway to
be honest
they have to teach them what they would
like because
i just don't vote like i don't think
like sex is that important like to be
honest like i just i think your values
is more important like
because i feel like sex can be learned
household yeah
so i get why you think that but i also
think do you think part of it is just
because being a woman as well not that
sex isn't important but
i think sex for guys is higher on the
value or priority less than it is for
girls there was a yeah i think there was
a there was a podcast with these two
famous american people i forget who is
there's a they're a couple
and
he was saying to her and it's like it's
a cup of tea have you seen it and he was
like you know as a man that dead podcast
that was it was cool
and yeah yeah and he was saying listen
you know as a man that my sex drive is
high and then she was like well you know
if i knew your sex was going to be this
high like oh i know what you're doing
and i was just like but you got married
and he was like but you kind of
coerced me into this marriage it was
like so yeah so his argument was like
if you if you
know that my sexual appetite is higher
than what you're willing to give why
would you enforce monogamy on me that's
what he said yeah and she was like i
didn't force you to do it yeah and that
was that whole back and forth but yeah
it's a really interesting point yeah
cause he's like well if he's he's gonna
want his sexual appetite taken care of
and you you as my wife cannot do it so
what do i now do yeah but you'd be
pissed off if i went out and cheated
right
so get your act together girl no i i i
said on one of the shows that i i think
that sex was a duty in marriage and
people were like did not agree at all
no i think it's a duty as a wife that's
what you're supposed to do my mom told
me i asked her because her and uh my dad
had been married like 30 years almost
i'm guessing and i asked her and she was
like i just say yes
that's why i have so many siblings
but the thing is as a man
generally
you don't want to know a woman's not
enjoying it yeah i don't know
do you know
i get what you're saying and i don't
necessarily disagree with it entirely i
do to a certain extent i just wouldn't i
don't think i'd be
turned on by a woman who's having sex
with me because she feels it's her duty
yeah i want i want that desire to be
reciprocated if it's not reciprocated
i'd rather not participate yeah
personally how how often yeah do you
think
couples should have sex that's how old
i think it depends on your relationship
yeah it depends on your relationship
at least once a week yeah yeah you might
get at least i think that um
that's one of the reasons people cheat
sometimes is because the wife is like
holding out
have you heard that
yes
yeah
like that when you said guys are either
monogamous or not monogamous i was
thinking earlier that
i think sometimes like men cheat because
of like the position they're sort of put
in like the girl like won't sleep with
them hasn't slept with them in months
what do you think's going on
i always say if a woman's not sleeping
with you sleeping with
because women like sex too yeah people
act like only guys like this is very
true so if she's not sleeping with you
she's sleeping with you might have to
ask yourself that question
you might be getting it from elsewhere
bro
thank you for the super chats guys um
blue pilled unplugged eight to ten women
haven't developed their personalities
since they realized men wanted to smash
them headaches to deal with and they're
less skilled in bed gabby you're
watching that's my friend um is it one
dollar super chat um
the oh god i can't pronounce this
elaziah
i life
thank you for the five pounds super chat
i appreciate you guys thank you
all the donations are going towards i
want to get
three cameras up in here and i want to
get eight mics so i can host like more
people it'll be fun
so do you think so you think men and
women
on a
general basis do you think men and women
cheat for different reasons
yeah i think men cheat
as you know you know as a man men can
have sex with a hole in the wall bro
you don't
do you know i mean like we just cheat
because it's just something different
have you ever have you ever hooked up
with a girl and been like embarrassed
like like after you're like i cannot
believe yeah 100 yeah yeah because she
fulfilled the need at the time but
you're looking at alpha it's one of the
ones where you know when you they say
would like when you rub one out you're
not you come back to your senses right
you're like you know what let me just
not eat it do you do you feel like a guy
doesn't know if he likes a girl until he
sleeps with her
because what do they call it
yeah i thought it was
maybe that was what it was maybe yeah
maybe it's possible i think i think
if a guy likes a girl it will show in
the immediate moments after he's just
finished yeah because if he's like oh
cool yeah
yeah yeah yeah
he's like wanting to hold her do you
know what conversation don't you guys
don't you guys think here let's say
you're gonna you're talking to a girl
but it's not a girlfriend yet yeah it
could be
like don't you ever think like because
this is what i think like what are we
gonna do after like and you bear in mind
you know you're gonna get there but in
your head you're like
what are you doing after that
no no
and you might be like you know what
i'm gonna
sometimes it's not even i'm going home
sometimes it's just what the hell did i
just do interpreting like why did i just
do this
because let's say after you're done she
just starts yapping off your ear and
you're just like bro shut up
like what
what's she saying you're not even trying
to hear
savage
what's she saying your name is trying to
hear about it but listen but then again
there's a flip side because the girl
could be same type of situation but what
she's talking is what you wanna hear
yeah i'm saying so in that in that
aspect then i feel like you know if you
like to go like you know what she's
kinda
but i think as you said straight after
yeah i don't know
but then again i think it's it's right
before
yeah it's right before because you know
if you're gonna hug the girl after you
after you have sex without that you know
yeah that's true if this is a girl you
wanna
that's a hug or because some girls you
might hug and they might take it the
wrong way like yo no man it's not wait
they'll take it the wrong way after you
slept together
like so not sheltered like i'm like yeah
i'm like aware of yeah right okay yeah
but yeah what he's saying is true like
yeah
that's so weird like you you just gave
him your body
right yeah no no but like but guys like
he said nobody like that but like he
said girls want sex too
yeah right right it's true it's not just
us i feel like okay this i feel like
this is the dating market okay where am
i in bare mind what i said no one's
dating yet we've just had no i i know
right now i think girls are afraid of
getting used for their body and guys are
getting afraid of getting used for their
yeah their resources
and that's why you have these girls that
hate men and these men that hate women
because at some point they've been you
one one group has been used for their
money at some point
or their time attention whatever it is
emotional you know friend zone whatever
on the other hand these girls think that
every all these guys are super sexually
active when it's just a small percentage
it goes about what you said about um
the truth like not a lot of people are
telling the truth when they first come
into our relationship and it's not even
just
relationships just like for normal
relationships like friendships yeah not
a lot of people didn't come in telling
the truth yeah you don't i don't think
that happens a lot so that could be
another
thing so if you're saying that like
women
are scared of being used for their body
um
a lot of women
now are just selling their body
oh yeah i know
that generally that you go to instagram
that's what they say
yeah they're certainly sexual but now to
be as now to say oh i'm afraid of being
used to my body it's like well what you
selling love do you know what you know
i'm so sorry let me just interject her i
saw this post on instagram saying
when you was in primary school or
secondary school the girl used to uh
that girl used to get sent nudes you
know when they go in primary school
secondary school she might have a nude
and they get sent around to everyone
right yeah they're like
i'm pissed off because now man gotta pay
5.99
yeah
that's come to my head but it's true
men are selling their resources as well
as in what i mean they're
they're portraying this certain
lifestyle
and that attracts
women but then what you can't get
complete you can't complain if the type
of women it attracts
that's the primary reason that they came
one hundred percent so it works both
ways
if if there wasn't
would you not think dayton would be
because what do you think people would
actually base
dating off if the internet was nothing
they based it off the individual
you'd have to you've got no choice i
think i think these things would still
play a part like they did before
so a woman being attractive a man having
resources of course i think that would
still definitely play a part i think the
difference is
people were just they were way limited
in their options
before
so they would have to choose actually
one thing that um
i kind of thought about recently is that
monogamy is a redistribution of sex
what do you mean what do you mean so
like for example okay so if you take
if you take a 10 random 10 guys and
random 10 girls and you put them on a
deserted island right you know because
of not just hypergamy but just the way
things are
more than likely what will happen is
you'll get seven or eight of those girls
will want the same two or three guys
right right okay so
if we live in a polyamorous society
right where one guy can be
involved with multiple women
let's say you get those top three guys
at the ten and let's say they each have
three girls each
yeah so then you have one girl who's
available and you have the seven other
guys fighting for it which is basically
how it is right now
but then if you enforce monogamy
you force those three guys to choose one
woman
right so they so they choose one so
they're no longer available to play with
anymore so the seven other girls they
stopped fighting for them because
they're off the market so they go back
to the other pool of men
and then everybody gets matched up
so monogamy is almost like
but those women will still want those
three guys they might but they'll choose
but they can't get them so they'll
choose someone else
[Music]
those three guys might have been their
first choice
but because they're off the market
if they want someone they're forced to
go back to the pool of men and to choose
from there
whereas if you live in a polyamorous
society which we're starting to already
you know the the cliche is you know
they'd rather share the top dog than 100
they're faithful usual to themselves
because women generally now they want a
guy who has that potential to
attract other women
yes well like you don't want some i
don't think men or women want someone
that nobody else wants no i mean there
are definitely societies men just cover
up their women and we're like no one
else can look at this one just say i
think men would okay she's mine
men would pro like i don't i don't think
men have
uh the same
pre
take the same pre-selection from other
men about a woman yeah that's true i
agree yeah yeah yeah cause i remember
when i was at drama school there was
this one girl in my year that half the
guy's like oh she's amazing and i just
never saw her sorry but just because
they were all falling over her that
didn't make her more attractive to me
because i just yeah
you kind of isolate as well as i feel
like i don't know for women they may see
an average guy and not think twice but
if they see loads of girls swarming here
they're like who's that who is this yeah
yeah like why is he this good one yeah
you know what i mean yeah
that's very interesting
but that's that's humans you know like
everyone left we saw if you heard
shouting outside
big loud chat were you gonna go look
outside yeah no it's true but like and
no disrespect because i think she's
incredibly talented but no matter how
many guys want lizzo she's just not my
type
do you know what i mean liza was a lot
of guys
personally someone out there maybe i
don't know no i'm just saying in general
like if you look at the attractiveness
scale yeah she's not really high on the
socially commercially attractiveness
scale is she unfortunate i think she has
a pretty face i think if she lost weight
she'd be pretty cute actually yeah but
if she lost weight that would just
go against everything that she is yeah i
feel sorry for her she because she said
it's like the whole thing that she's
like adele used to be the
poster girl for for big girls larger
incredible artists and then she lost
that weight and she got so much hate
yeah well i don't know why as like why
do we lie to women we do not look better
fatter like what i don't understand
that's body shaming it's not it's just
it's just
i wouldn't i'm not counseling i'm sorry
if i gained 100 pounds i would not be
cute like
why is that that's not crazy
why do you why do you but women say that
i said this though why do you because
there's no body positivity for men no no
look what happened to 50 cent the other
day eighty percent yeah what happened to
rick ross over there right now 50 came
out at the halftime super bowl
doing his uh
uh song yeah and he had put on weight he
put the same vest on that he had back in
the day and he looked people slaughtered
him yeah yeah yeah if that was a woman
no well 80 of consumer buying decisions
are made by women and women so we're
always selling to women yeah
and they get some dreams
maybe that's why they always lie to you
yeah yeah of course they get so dreams
and the thing is like i said women tell
each other lies as well like they'll
tell your girlfriend oh you look great
in that dress knowing that she looks
like a fat whale
we're more agreeable
yeah that's why yeah
even even sometimes when i'm running
this show it's really hard for me to
tell people to shut the f up when they
keep talking like you guys it's funny
when it's only girls that do it right
like it's
like when i have got a group of guys in
here it's like very it's very like
it's very bad
so girls are like screaming
you were there everyone kept cutting
each other off
it's not i'm like agreeable so it's not
but the thing is if you're around women
like that right
what it is it's very interesting though
that when you're around women like that
and they're just screaming and doing all
that
if you don't get in
yeah and just [ __ ] discipline the
[ __ ] thing yeah then they're just
gonna think whatever i will keep going
but then when you try to do that they
get offended yeah yeah he's talking to
me
listen
no no that happened that happened to me
not the show you were at but a different
show i did like i had a girl text me and
like because i told her to like shut up
basically
she was mad yeah
yeah it's like what did you say when she
texted you i mean i just said um i don't
know i just said i didn't mean it like
that like it was just you kept talking
but then would you say that that's
because you are more
you are less quote-unquote
female than them
do you think that is then you're more
aware gosh i mean i'm like
like saying i'm less female
[Applause]
i'm very logical i get it from my dad
like my dad's very logical so that's
that's kind of why i like this stuff
because i really like numbers and i've
always researched random things since i
was like a kid
so and i grew up between two boys so
maybe that's why right in the packing
order i was right okay guys i don't know
because so you know sometimes i feel
like
it sounds like
bad and quite misogynistic but sometimes
like i said on the podcast when all the
girls were there
it's just like you feel like
you guys need to be disciplined like
children sometimes it's not like no yeah
like just
and it's like oh that's misogynistic
because no sometimes when women get no
it's and it's hard because it's not it's
it doesn't come naturally to me it does
not oh that's not my personality i was
like
you need someone to play bad cop for you
that's why
i do
like once they get going it's just like
oh my god they're disgusting they're all
on the gas each
it's like calm down
but the thing is if you say that it's
like oh you're a misogynist oh oh you're
trying to control me all this kind of
stuff it's like no but we can actually
see that though it's so it's so funny i
did i had two girls on um on my channel
a couple of weeks ago and my producer
who's on there i'm not gonna say which
girl it was obviously because you might
watch this um but one of the girls after
the session he like after she left he's
just like
boy she just taught and talked
i was like yeah it was meant to be a
conversation but it ended up just being
a monologue to be honest
but i know i think i think a lot of
people i think we can all get like that
over something we're passionate about
do you know what i mean when when when
you talk about something that you're
very passionate about people
can get carried away with it yeah but i
think i think guys communicate
differently from women yeah i just think
we communicate differently they were
very direct like people were saying
we're on yeah and we're on the show this
is quite civilized no one's screaming
over one another like you seen a man
he's in a boy's group so you seen a
boy's group yeah yeah
i don't know if how it was for you when
you're young actually i think it i think
it was um
it should have been like this when you
you were young but you if you've got a
fat guy in your group you're a group of
guys you're a fat guy shut up and you're
fat yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and obviously he ain't taking no effects
no offense to it like that but yeah
girls are not available it will say
something about you yeah exactly exactly
i'm like yeah shut up whatever
your toe looks like one two whatever and
then you
the girls
i think is the complete opposite in
terms of oh yeah okay you're not fat
isn't it oh i imagine the person is fat
oh you're beautiful like bro they lie to
you
you're your friend like bro just tell
her to get it it's not like i lie to
people but
who am i to comment on the way you look
it's more like i just keep my opinions
to my damn self not about not about you
you know it's gonna cause
something amongst women yeah but it
depends how you say it what intent you
have when you say it well when i okay
because i was a college athlete so i did
like basketball volleyball and i rent
track and then when i finished it
my eating habits let me tell you they
caught up to me like like real quick
because i wasn't working out like four
hours a day right yeah and i gained a
lot of weight and i wouldn't want anyone
to comment on it like i ended up losing
it once i figured out you know how to
eat less
[Music]
but like i don't know it's like
would it help me if someone tells me i
already knew you know
maybe it's because you know if we're
being honest as well there's there's
more of a um pressure on women on their
appearance i feel like
so maybe that's why it's kind of like
we're valued more for it yeah yeah which
is a double-edged sword i feel
it can be a double-edged sword because i
feel like now
i think now like women
are judging
more so other women
you know what i mean you think they're
judging other women more yeah i think
women are like
judging other women a lot but not saying
it so
i said like a woman
can walk into this room
and if there's like three if there were
like three females around this table if
a woman walks in
they're thinking who's this [ __ ]
they're thinking like because they're
eyeing her up they're looking at their
competition and especially if there's a
guy in the room yes no i mean like if
there's a guy in the room they're
thinking
what's look at her shoes they're looking
at her shoes looking at her hair yeah
her makeup the way you know they're
looking at all of that whereas i said a
guy
if there's if we're around
guy generally yeah yeah because there
are guys that you know do the same but
generally if we're around our guys and
the woman walks in
you seen this
actually i was thinking about how you
three didn't know each other and you
guys
like kind of talk like your friends even
though you don't know each other
like it would not be the same if it was
three girls i don't think no not that
didn't know we should like but didn't
know each other yeah that's so funny i
find i feel like
i feel like
maybe because for girls there's less
guys that they
would choose
that when they come across a guy that
they want
which is usually a guy that other girls
want they're like well i have to make
sure i get get him
because i think for the average girl
like out of 50 guys that will approach
her she'll give like two of them a
chance whereas if you're a guy a 50 girl
if 50 girls approach you giving all 50 a
chance
like a chuck
that doesn't mean you'll go there
yeah let's see what happens so i think
for guys it's like a really hot girl
watching like okay my man gets her it's
okay there's plenty of other fish in the
sea that i could choose from right
whereas for girls they're like
if a girl only chooses like two percent
of guys if there's a guy that's in the
room that's one of those guys listen
it's war yeah
it's warm actually i always say my um
my my friend and i kind of have a
similar type and we'll say there's
nothing that'll bring like two girls
together faster than having the same
type and then drive them apart
so did you ever both like the same guy
no
um
no because
like usually if she likes a guy like
he'll just have a friend right you know
so
but no i haven't been single that long
though so we'll see i guess so you're
not currently actively looking to get
into a relationship then at this point
um i wanted to stay single because i was
in a relationship for like a year so i
wanted to stay single for like six
months maybe
like i don't know i feel like you should
i agree yeah like half the time of the
relationship try to stay single that
means i've got another two years of
single life
that means i still got another four
months i think four or five months i
don't know yeah
i've never been in a relationship and i
have i have my last solution was
two and a two and a half years oh you
are quit
yes what do you mean you are good you
can have anything you want
but i don't know i think though let's
just be honest you meet the right guy
then you don't care
yeah yeah
you know some girls meet the right guy
in a relationship
and someone else's man too
it happens it happens
to stop you from finding your way
what a statement listen what a statement
actually i remember when i got to the
age where married guys would start to
hit on me it was so it made me so sad oh
really yeah because you i don't know you
hit like like when you turn 21-22
and you start to see how many people
like cheat
it's like very most people cheat
so let me say let me not say most sorry
a lot of people cheat
oh yeah i think i like it
i take that right it's like one and four
and those are the ones that admit it
it's very true the one that admitted
those are the ones that admit it like
all the surveys that have been done
about people cheating people have got to
admit it in the first place to get the
survey done that's true well i think i
think okay this is a weird comparison
and i don't know if you guys are going
to see it but i think it comes back to
working hard i think it's really hard to
find people that are just like really
hard workers and i think it's the same
thing in a relationship like everyone
has the tendency to like stray you know
women are we're hypergamous
so we have a natural tendency to leave
you the second something better comes
along and then have a natural tendency
to hook up with every girl that walks by
you know but i don't know i think it's
it's kind of how hard you work at it you
know at what exactly the resilient at
relationships
and having a good and like healthy
relationship yeah
but you've got to work it relationships
are work man
they are they're actually work
kind of work on yourself and the other
person at the same time no like in terms
of like
you see temptation over here over here
you might drop your kids to school you
might see one of the other moms yeah
i've got to that age where like i've got
like really young girls hitting on me or
like much older older women
yeah yeah like yeah literally like i
remember like i was um
in the middle of like a show
in between the matinee and the evening
show i just went to get some dinner
pizza express near me this is north
london
and the waitress very attractive girl
she's nice and she was young
yeah and she was like making
she was actively talking to me so hold
on so what do you do whatever
i was like yeah i'm in this show she was
like okay and then she even was like oh
well just so you know like i work here
like thursday and friday so like
she was like i'm here you know i'm here
yeah
so i was like what's your name and she's
oh she's a medical student and she said
i heard the word student and i was like
how old are you
she was 18. oh wow and i was like ah
dead
it's like damn i think it's i'm an
anomaly because most women have dated
have been older than me
oh really
yeah interesting way yeah yeah why um
and how
um i think if i like like i've had fun
with like girls my own age stuff like
that but like
it kind of
sounds really harsh i think
when it comes to dating and
maybe relationships i feel quite
i think i'm more emotionally mature than
a lot of people my own age
so i tend to be on a more similar
frequency with
people who are older than right okay um
and it's not about the age thing it's
just about the emotional maturity thing
and you know
like a lot of people have said there are
a lot of attractive girls out there but
then because they've kind of been given
everything they may not have worked on
certain elements of their character yeah
so it's great to have sex and have fun
but then outside of that you're kind of
like what else is there do you know what
i mean um but yeah i've just always
found that now i generally don't go for
women who are tens
like who were like on the attractiveness
girl
no at all
why not you're sure no no not because i
couldn't shoot my show not because i
couldn't get them i just
i'm thinking
you've
you've got about 50 other guys
like
i'm not going to be that guy just let
them guess you i'm not going to do the
one i'm not going to be the one i'm the
same actually that's actually yeah yeah
i'm not going to be him that's the only
way to stand out is to not shoot your
shoulder yeah with those kinds of girls
i feel if they come to me so be it
that's right yeah but i'm not going to
them
huh
yeah so you know what you know
you know earlier when i said oh this
happened where like a very very
attractive girl who's actually
the reason they made a move on me is
because i was their type to a t
that's the only case as you know when i
like i wouldn't try with something like
that because they've got 50 other guys
trying it
but if they're into you and you're the
only guy not hitting on them that makes
you stand out right
right
and the thing is i said that whole oh
you've got 50 other guys hitting on you
gives them a certain
ego
that i'm just not willing to deal with
no one of them
[Music]
because
certain girls might have that caliber of
looks
and um the guys will speak to them
and
and like they will give let's say they
give every guy a chance they'll be like
you know you're just off or you do like
you're only here because i look nice and
yeah for her she's like okay cool you
guys are after this this materialistic
thing you guys want me to be a trophy so
for her it might be you know what i
understand i get a lot of guys so i'm
not even gonna talk to you a lot no more
and then let's say the guy's like like
you guys know that said
you're not even gonna move to her
she might not even care because she's
like bro you might be like the rest of
these guys trying to
just be materialistic so and she might
be smart she might be like you know i
know i know what game you're trying to
play yeah some girls are really like
that yeah no it's just like
yeah yeah that's that's that's just the
point
literally well go on it's interesting
i've heard that from so many guys that
to tens are for the streets because when
i when i rate people this is my scale
okay
eight to ten means you're pretty enough
to model
okay yeah sevens don't exist because
everyone thinks they're seven
so i don't get that from kevin's
you actually know the scale then so like
five is like pretty to cute five six
pretty cute yeah eight to ten is like
you that's why when they said nicki
minaj wasn't an eight i was like she's a
model yes she is and facial symmetry
yeah yeah right yeah i hear you're
saying
i mean give me a s give me a six who's
got a great personality
i'm good
yeah yeah what's a good what's a good
personality to you guys
let me not say just good personality
just
the right qualities that i desire in a
woman
what are those
um
they're just the same things that men
talk about all the time
um
so besides i think he's gonna be a good
mother besides the things that men talk
about all the time what what are the
ones that are different for you
what do you mean
you said what do you like specifically
yeah um i like a woman who likes to
learn
okay like i like a woman who has a mind
to want to learn new things
that's what i like
um so because i'm always reading
something i'm always researching
something i'm always doing something and
to have like
fruitful conversation is a thing for me
yeah yeah i want to be able to
intellectually yeah i want to have a
fruitful conversation with somebody
because i may be sexy attract you and we
may you know [ __ ] each other's brains
out or whatever but
after that i want to know that if we
have a conversation it's going to be
fruitful we can talk about politics yes
you know i mean we can talk about
religion or we can talk about whatever
it is you know what i mean we can talk
about the world and social issues
yeah would you guys date a feminist hell
no yeah yeah
are you not do you consider yourself a
feminist
uh
no
i don't know
not not modern day feminist no i mean i
believe equality for men and women but
i wouldn't call myself a feminist today
no but you'd date one
i would be opposed to it depends what
kind of feminist she is yeah that's what
yeah that's what i think it depends on
the men hating feminism oh let's
let's say she's nice enough right cute
enough nice enough whatever like nice
person yeah but
she believes in like
you know the feminist ideology
so okay give me some examples um
women are not patriarchy there's a
patriarchy just destroyed
women women
are not paid the same as men which isn't
true yeah that's not true
um
let's see women heard that i'm like what
well it's just like a certain
lo i meet a lot of really nice people
that just have like a low level disdain
for men but they're really like nice
people people yeah to be around whatever
but i just i noticed it's very common
and girls that i meet so i'll tell you
what i think yeah what my kind of that
they have so do they have a disdain for
men yeah and it's it's subtle a lot of
the time it's not it's not right out in
your face it's like very subtle um
um for example if i if i mention like a
men's rights rights issue a lot of times
their first reaction is well well women
what about that
it's just like a low level
my kind of um
my kind of approach with it and that's
not saying that i would choose somebody
off that
you know i think likelihood i probably
wouldn't like for long term
but i kind of see it as like
their kind of mentality and thinking is
a result of the climate they've grown up
in so it's kind of like you know anybody
any of these what if anyone who's dated
a white girl if you've met her
grandparents they probably didn't like
you for that very reason
and their grandparents were probably
racist but then they're racist
personally attacked
well i'm just saying my grandparents are
part of the kkk
my grandparents are very nice thank you
no it's true but like
i think it's more like you're talking
generally i'm talking general i'm
talking in general and i think
i don't hold it
against them
because they are a result of their
generation like if they were born today
i don't think they've had they'd have
the same views right so i think with
quote-unquote extreme feminists yeah me
and extreme feminism get along like i'll
be honest especially in my industry i've
clashed with a lot of people
i love creative types i've clashed with
a lot of people yeah um but
i've had it where
i'll be honest there's a girl that um i
dated
recently where
she used to be that kind of girl
she used to be that kind of girl we used
to have debates like every week right
and then we started dating because not
because she came out that mindset but
then she came out of that mindset and
came to more
actually aware of what's actually going
on right
and then that
lined up for us does that make sense
so but she was probably debating you
because she was attracted to the fact
attracted to the fact that you
weren't agreeable with her maybe and
it's so funny all her friends turns out
i know
i'm just having a conversation with
someone about this how it's like it's
like fighting it's almost like
attractive when i get argues with you a
little bit yeah
like a little bit no i know women like
that yeah like it's true like you know
someone who's not especially a man not
afraid to say his mind
even if it's doesn't
and i'll never you know if someone asks
my opinion i'm going to give my honest
opinion right
um i want to ask you a question okay
what do you think of
men who
strongly proclaim themselves to be
feminists oh i can't
i can't oh my gosh no i don't
i won't give them the time of day tell
us what
because i'm [ __ ]
because i just don't consider myself a
feminist and i think that whole ideology
is just toxic and i just don't agree
with it and i feel very very strongly
about this yeah so i think that a guy
that has the complete opposite ideology
as me
would just be like right like i
i just don't believe him
i feel like i feel like they're
disingenuous
[Applause]
um yeah most of them i think and that's
like the first thing you could tell me
to like want to get
yeah yeah yeah
like i went on a date with a male
feminist then he asked me to pay half i
was like i see where you
were i see what you i see
well and then it was crazy because he
wanted to go back and i said no and he
got mad i was like where am i right
no means i was like where
sorry you just asked me if i believe in
population control
i just remember thinking like this is
you were talking to the wrong [ __ ]
right now
like
i was just thinking like he probably
thinks this is going like well yeah
because i'll i'll talk like i'm a chit
chatter right you know
and i'm agreeable so i just kind of sit
there
yeah
he's like doing well here
we go
that's probably more dangerous for guys
because they just don't know where they
stand with you
yeah well that's why i don't like
there's a lot of guys that like i'll
start like talking to and then i realize
that they're they're super laughed and i
just can't it's yeah
i couldn't like be with a girl who's
like really far left it's weird because
like i
if you ask me 10 years ago
i would have said
that i'm left-wing
[Music]
but now i wouldn't say that but that's
not because my because my values have
changed it's because the goal posts have
changed yeah like what's now considered
left wing is like
you know like for example
i don't know i remember seeing this
thing a few years ago where like people
who were pedophiles were trying to get
involved the lgbtq community because
they were like oh well it's i was born
this way so that's normal there was a
whole thing there was a little template
with that there was a whole ted talk on
it was that yeah on why on why
pedophilia is a sexual choice oh
i will never be on board yeah
so it's like so there's something as
well like
oh one thing i've definitely clashed
with people in my industry when they say
um when they say black people can't be
racist
i'm like that's nonsense anyone can be
racist like it may affect people
differently what do you think racism is
then
because that's that's the question that
i always say when that when people say
that like what do you think racism
actually is i think it's an illusion
[Music]
i think it's an illusion just because
you see all the people that are racist
right now
it was taught to them
it's true it was taught because let's be
honest like 500 years ago those people
ain't alive yeah so
growing up you had to
say something to your kids for
racism to still go on
[Music]
all these mps that are racist
like they are they are the the white
kids that that their parents were like
listen you're gonna go out there well
their parents might have certain
conversations in front of them to make
them think that certain things are okay
so you know how some you hear people say
oh what's normal for you
normal for them is
not liking black people yes you know
what i'm saying yeah so but i think all
people are race prejudice to some degree
do you think they're race prejudice or
do you think they're
by race bias yeah like
everyone has racial bias to some degree
you can't you can't grow up in the
western world and not have any kind of
rights
to some degree we're biologically
predispositioned to categorize people
yeah yeah
yeah
it's because your brain can't process
like and it's kind of happens even when
um like if i if i meet a girl like i
kind of want to see is she is she super
feminist is she super like and that's me
categorizing her you know where did she
grow up do we grow up in similar or
different you know
areas because i think institutional
racism is when you have that that that
conversation yes i think institutional
racism
is a thing i think individual racism
is nothing to me like if a guy if i go
into the shop now and the guy serving me
for i was a n-word yes
is that adversely affecting my life well
that's my point as in like there could
be races but it can it impact it can
impact you differently like right
depending who's doing it right now these
officers right so that's an ins so the
institution yes is a thing
but
crazy is that your dog she's fine
when
people say
that black people can't be racist i
think that's what they mean they what
the i think what i think they mean is
that we don't have an institution we
don't have the power to enforce
that type of thing and i think that's
what they mean and and i
i agree with that like me being racist
to you will probably have very little
impact compared to you being racist to
me if you were like
maybe if we were in public or i don't
know or whatever you're not going to
adversely impact pearl's life by calling
her something no because pearl's still
going to wake up tomorrow do our
podcasts and you know get things done
it's going to happen so but when you
have the power to influence her yeah you
had an army and you didn't like her
because of what she looked like yeah and
it's a problem i agree
like it's definitely a problem
i think that was the argument they were
saying that racism is prejudice plus
power
which i understand to some degree but
then i think i see racism as a behavior
and it's just you're discriminated on
someone because of the color of their
skin
anyone can do that any yeah anyone can
do that anyone can pre-judge someone
based on the quality skin how do you
guys feel about things like affirmative
action
um
i understand i don't know if you guys
have it here
it's in the
can you can you u.s
you define exactly what you mean before
we um when i think of affirmative action
i think of like quotas
um but for example i could even think of
one with women so i worked in um a sales
like copier role and it was very male
like i was the only girl in the office
and um they would always try to get
girls to work there but it was a
terrible job so of course
i think the best person for the job
should get the job always right yeah i
think the reason why affirmative action
exists specifically in america is
because there was a huge time where it
doesn't even matter whether you're the
best person or not if you're black
you're just not getting the job you know
it's like
you could be better than the white dude
but we ain't gonna hire your black ass
do you know what i mean like that's what
was a time in america for a very long
time so i understand why it exists i i
agree i think yeah go on no no no i um
my parents are both in the corporate
world right
and you know they've you know rose to
like partner level etcetera etcetera and
all this
and it's like if you had a team
like a sales team
if there was a black individual on the
team you knew they were the best one
and because if they weren't the best one
they wouldn't be on that team
right there's a different standard
because they had to work harder to get
there because people have their own
biases
so if for example
if a white man is hiring
is he going to hire the nigerian
immigrant
who has the same standard as
the next white fella right who grew up
down the road from him right his natural
biases are going to go there and we all
have natural biases so which is why i
think there is a good argument to
have
to make the people at the top diverse
because it means that more people get to
exercise their biases
does that make sense
but okay
there is a because we do have our
natural biases it's not necessarily a
level playing field all the time which
is why there is i think some validity to
affirmative action but i don't like
quotas
i don't think
if i have a company and i'm filling
positions i'm all about the bottom line
so i'm taking the best person i don't
care what color creed they are
because that makes sense
really that it makes sense to take the
best person but also i think that's why
companies where they are if they're very
money driven
it it doesn't make sense to not if you
think someone's best for the job i.e
they're going to make you the most money
you would always take them
however
my bias as a black person yeah right
i have a bias because um
on the social economic ladder in the
west in
in the globe
black people tend to occupy the bottom
of the social economic ladder yeah no
matter what country you go to
right
so
my bias is like oh i want us to get off
the bottom of the social you're going to
ladder oh yeah yeah you know what i'm
saying so
come bro
i hear that you know what i'm saying so
that's my i know that's my advice do you
know what i'm saying because but i'm
i'm only like that because of the social
economic condition that we currently
have i'm not doing it because i hate
another person yes
i'm saying like i'm just like bro
listen i know
right i get it yeah let me try and work
with you so it's like i know i have a
bias like that i actually know that
within myself yeah do you feel the same
about like dating
like because um i don't know what it is
here but in the us um like black girls
are the least married
so do you feel like that same
like we you're trying to no like i my
all of my girlfriends have been black
right really yeah all of them
like you've never dated anyone who
wasn't black no not even casually not
even casually
interesting um so
but that's because that's my
preference yeah yeah yeah i'm saying
like i like black women yeah you know i
mean like that's just my son's black his
mom's black like oh my god
so you kind of sort of yeah the answer
kind of is yeah
the thing is yeah so it's like
i'm not dating because of pity it's like
oh i see you at the bottom girl come on
yeah
it's that's just who i am my has been
very mixed
right but i think part of part of the
reason is because
like you know united like theater
training
like i started theater training when i
was younger so they're all private
schools
and nine times
i was the only black guy there right
okay so mine i've dated more black girls
since graduating because i've been
exposing to the world
does that make sense right but most of
my environments have been and not so
just white but like you know half the
students would be international
so right um
but yeah but it's interesting though
because
it is true that black women in the west
are at least married however black
immigrant women are the most married
i would believe that do you know what
they have different cultural they have a
different culture
the girls at my church yeah i i could
definitely see that the the most
attractive i would say most attractive
guy at the church like married a black
girl and i think her parents were
immigrants or something yeah yeah from
what country do you know
an african country yeah right i don't
remember where i i remember i dated this
black south african girl once a few
years ago
um
and
um
every time i went to her house she would
often do my washing
every time i stayed over she cooked me
breakfast every morning before we went
into rehearsals or did the show
i had never had
any girl do that any woman do her ever
never really
not like that but because she was south
african
differently it's a different culture
yeah culturally it's different it's like
south african women you were like i need
to marry this girl
we'll talk i was just like i'm gonna
have to marry her yeah yeah because i've
never met a girl like this before
and that was the first time i was like
wow like
that's what i started to see oh well you
know we're talking about black women
where black women from different
cultures
that's why it's like
when black girls say oh they're the
least desired because of you know
eurocentric
beauty standards which i'm not saying
there isn't an element of that i think
there is
but then like i said it's like well
black women from other cultures they
don't have a problem because different
mindset because like you're saying that
like the girl was talking about the last
one
she was from uganda
right culturally
amazing she tipped every single box i
was like oh my god i'm going to marry
this girl i could actually see myself
marrying this girl um but you know jesus
cop blocked and all that
but
like it's it's true like
black women from different cultures
are different from western black women
they are they are
well it's interesting because they
always say like
they'll leave you for like a becky or
whatever right but that has not been my
experience because i've i have two
ex-boyfriends and they like they both
were black and like they left me for a
black girl
or like when we broke up the next girl
they dated was black so i was like
i don't know
how old were they can i ask do you want
me
he's about to turn 24 so you're younger
and then
well
trying to think i was a sophomore but i
was a year young for my grades i was
like 18.
i think like he was four years older so
when you're younger and then four years
older so now
but i think one of the things that is
not touched on one one of the things
that people try to stray away from
generally because it's a little bit like
controversial yeah is that the
fetishization
that people have in certainly like
interracial relationships
i think to some degree it is a
fetishization and i'm not saying in all
related interracial relationships i'm
not saying that but i think to some
degree
there's that oh my god i shouldn't even
be here but i love it
but it's great oh my god i shouldn't be
doing it that's still the case now
subconscious yeah do you think do you
think white girls
feel that way now because we're so
emotionally you see when i grow up
you see when i grow up right i'm 40
right so i grew up in an era where
the black guy was the cool guy to white
girls
he was always the cool guy he was the
guy that
was a little bit more dangerous he was a
little bit more to something that she
shouldn't do but she's doing it and
she's kind of rebelling against what her
parents say and all this kind of stuff
right you know what i'm saying so yeah
it's actually there was an element of
i'm doing this to be a rebel
yes a forbidden yeah would you say that
was the same for
so you know as we said like in the west
the majority of the black community are
in the working class mm-hmm would you
say that was the same for white girls
and working class
yeah like i got approached like i i
won't lie if i when i was go to clubs
right with my friends right black guys
and if we were to go to clubs that were
like mostly white girls
the white girls would stop
they wouldn't even give a [ __ ] about the
white guys anymore yeah they would stop
they'll be like there's some black guys
here girls yeah you know i mean this
that whoa is that to see that it's like
oh that was interesting but then
a club that's all white
it's probably not a working-class club
it's a working-class club it's
black people indian people yeah like
chinese i mean it was in the west end
you know i mean but that's what i mean
so like if they're not i completely get
that if they're from if they're in a
class where it is very
majority white
but if they've grown up in a class where
it's very multicultural it's very mixed
like the black being like oh there's a
black guy it's like well yeah like
because don't get normal in it yeah it's
normal so i'd say like what i'm
questioning is is the fetishization
probably comes from those who are more
middle upper class because they haven't
been exposed to it as much whereas if
you've grown up with it is it really
fetishized i don't know that's what i'm
asking and i think a lot of black guys
fetishize white girls too
yeah
yeah you know what i think that's porn
listen i keep telling people
listen porn yeah
porn is the subconscious mind of the
nation
i keep telling people yes you know
what's the most looked up on
porn sites
interracial interracial no asian girls
see
yeah
and they're the most swiped on dating
apps
so there's a criticization of people
like interracial of the
i don't know you know the bbc it's a
thing on porn you go on board oh you
want to see the bbc it's a thing bro
like it's it's the subconscious mind of
the nation
but people don't want to talk about it
it's like when you go on porn it's like
what do you mean by some conscious mind
because what it is is a place in which
human beings walk around the streets
thinking these things about people right
yes they think these things but they
don't say these things but when they go
on the porn side they're allowed to like
indulge in that [ __ ] do you get what i'm
saying so it's like it's the
subconscious mind of the nation
it's the place where they feel
comfortable to express their fetishes
right and express what they really feel
like because what black guy can go out
in the public and say you know what i
really want to bang a white up asian
chick yeah he'll be cancelled yeah but
you can't say that [ __ ]
but
you can do it on the pawn side can i ask
you a question do you think you can
fetishize
your own race someone who's of the same
race to you hmm
um and if maybe
like of course i feel like maybe yeah
maybe was
like no one's safe
but i don't think about this i'm saying
like the human mind is
i love that talk like psychology like
stuff i think fetishizing is such a
weird conversation because it's more
like i just don't care who people date
if you want to date your own race or a
different race i just
i don't give a [ __ ] like i just don't
what i'm just care like when it comes to
what's on the minds of people i think a
lot of us like i said we're all lying to
one another we're lying to ourselves
like people are walking around lying
it's like if i was to go in your porn
searches now i'd figure out who to [ __ ]
you up
does body count matter if you never find
out
oh no no
if you never find out that no no you
don't know
do you guys ask girls what their body
count is when you start dating
it's pointless because they're going to
lie anyway
yeah but they're going to lie anyway i'm
not asking
but like i've i would rather not know i
i want to know to some degree i want to
know if you've had a chance so i'll tell
you the only reason i'd want to know i
don't want to know if you i wasn't
trying to pursue you if i'm trying to
pursue you don't tell me
really yeah
would you not want to know if you're the
woman that you would i want to know
something well i want to know is if i'm
with you and i'm thinking to get married
to you is the man you have had sex with
going to be at my wedding
that's what i want to know yeah and if
if he is at my wedding then no no i
can't yeah you know what i'm saying but
like if it's different you wouldn't know
if your one was like a prostitute before
you or something
listen does the man know me
and is he going to come to our wedding
is he going to be a part of our lives am
i going to meet him
i tell you what it matters to me
everyone has a cv
or a resume okay for pearl right
your cv
shows what your past behavior in your
job has been it shows what you can do
and it normally you're hired on your cv
because it shows what you're probably
gonna do in the future um oh your cv if
you've been a prostitute you might be a
prostitute in the future
yeah i don't know yeah but you can't you
ask different questions to find out
those things i think yeah okay so i
think you wouldn't ask directly like yo
what's your body count but i think when
you get to know someone without asking a
question you can gauge what it is
you can engage and sometimes they
because they might ask you what about
you would you want to know
[Music]
i'm nosy i always ask
i'm just like i thought she was gonna
lie to you i am i'm very nosy
so
but the thing is you you'd prefer
a guy with
a high body count or a low one
uh lower i'd rather there be less exes
but i'm like practical in the way i
think it doesn't mean i'm attracted to
it there's a difference between like
dating like like wanting something
because it's like practical and like
being attract like obviously women are
attracted to like men that other or
men that other women want right but like
at the same like the way i think is
i just rather there be less exes in
general and crazy girls ex-girlfriends
or do you mean
like either crazy can be either or
especially if he's like a good-looking
guy i'm like
i don't i don't want all these exes
and i don't oh my gosh and i need to
know if you slept with any of like the
girls around
oh
what have you slept with your friends oh
it's over
if he's a really desirable guy
and he only casually had sex with like
one or two of her friends if she gets
commitment that's like an ego boost for
her
but it's like
because you gotta now worry about that
friend
yeah yeah and because i just think
different because i get like again it's
the same reason i rejected the guy that
was too good-looking
yeah because it's just i get i get
nervous like i'd rather just
i don't want a guy that nobody else i
don't know i guess i can't win
i don't i don't know
but i don't know because i get this like
anxiety and i just think that would give
me anxiety
like knowing that he hooked up with one
of my friends i found out oh one of my i
found out that i go i was seeing one
time
had slept with like one of my friends
it's a rap for me no but it was
so far down the line
that we were like getting we got into a
relationship because i didn't tell one
of my boys
we got into a relationship
and then like one day we're having a
conversation and she was just like
oh yeah this guy used to know called
so-and-so and i was like okay cool and
she said she said the area and i was
like
oh um
does he drive this car she was like yeah
and i was like
did you sleep with him she was like yeah
oh that's different yeah okay and i was
like
[ __ ] that's one of my boys
oh [ __ ] i was like
no are you serious i was like yeah
that's my proper close guy like oh
really and she was like
do you guys like compare notes no but i
was like
what can you do if you've started a
relationship with this person i think at
that point do you know what i'm saying
what did you do afterwards if we
continued our relationship i think it
was dead
i went to go and tell my boy how was
that bro
what was that conversation like like
what was what i was like brother i just
i need to i see you man she's like yeah
i went around and i was like you know
her and he was like yeah yeah
and i was like
you used to see her right and he was
like yeah i said how long ago
and it was like over like a year and a
half ago
okay cool my boy is going to tell me he
doesn't know that i'm with her already
like yeah i was like
that's my girl you know
and he was like
serious
i was like yeah he was like
it was a problem sorry i said there's
nothing to apologize for yeah is that
like you didn't know you didn't know i
didn't know yeah yeah it was like so
we're gonna do and i was like you know
what kind of involved bro like what kind
of like
he's like do your thing yeah yeah i
think if it was a long time ago because
i'm only like i'm only 25.
so i was thinking if it was a long time
ago maybe and if the other person was
like married or something
right yeah
you're like zero chance for it to happen
again
yeah
but if it was a long time yeah if it was
a long time ago and like in that like if
she was married you know and it wasn't
yeah i probably or maybe just dropped
the front yeah
i think i think buddy can't
my rule for me is
as long as her body count is less than
mine
that's what i've noticed with a guy but
you might have like 500 bro she might
have
200.
that's true but i don't have that but no
because i don't i don't just
i think if you
it sounds really wanky
like i wouldn't just
i don't just sleep with girls that i
find attractive like that anymore i used
to be like that but then it got to a
point where i'm like
i value my sexual energy
right
do you know what i mean
it's a thing yeah and it sounds
lame but like some people just don't
deserve your sexual energy it's not lame
it's about
you more so than them yeah do you know
what people do when you say that is he
gay
he must be funny hey no no the thing is
i get what you're saying yeah totally
get what you're saying but people start
with like oh my god is he gay that whole
shame
guilt
that old sign language thing comes in
because women want to know
most women haven't been rejected right
especially sexually yeah
and when they do they just they go in
they go in they go in when they get
sexually rejected they go oh you must be
you must be gay don't you
don't you think women feel entitled
to what
everything
i'm so serious because like i feel like
men do anything for for women nowadays
and it's like
oh i was on the i was on the train the
other day
and you know when you're coming off the
train
then people gotta come move out your way
so you can yeah because you got a
girlfriend you know what i'm saying so
they can get on
there's a woman in like in the mid in in
front of me
like the door's open she's standing
right on the track and i'm looking at
like and bear in mind there's loads of
people i'm looking at like blood like
everyone's waiting
for you to move because we've got
here at the office after i'm off the
train
bro she didn't move
she didn't
move she just she looked me dead in my
eye i was like
i said that blood like i'm not gonna
move so i just went away i was like all
right cool and i've
that happened and it's mad because i
found that
when i realized that that happened to me
i started looking out for it because in
my head i was like
because in that moment i feel because
she was she was she was a nice woman by
the way yeah she was a very attractive
woman in my head i was thinking
these women think they should own the
world cool
walked up the road now at my map where i
live
you know when like you might be walking
up the road and like there's bushes here
so you kind of gotta move from the
bushes right yeah cool i'm moving
and the woman's obviously coming this
way
and she's not moving out my way bear man
she can see the bushes as well
you know what i'm saying
like what do you expect me to wait for
you like i got [ __ ] to do too late but i
think they feel entitled man i told you
a lot of things to a lot of things man
and i do feel like it's mental if that's
yeah it's men's fault y'all like who do
you think made them like this that's
true it's not women it's true i think
it's true
like men really did sympt for women yeah
for decades didn't they like yeah but i
said on your last show
the reason why they've done it is
because they were asked to do it because
men essentially want to get women i
think it's kind of natural to guys to be
honest i think men want to help women
like if i it's true i
um and if they ask you for something
you're going to want to you're going to
want to help them
no like i've had guys help me with just
like random stuff over the years like
fixing a tire or like like whatever you
know
so random guys are guys you know
both okay
but i think i think because
so statistically speaking
99 of women have reproduced historically
but only like 38 of men have i thought
it was 40 and 80 no
what women who have reproduced
i thought i was 80 and 40 man oh i've
heard it's like 99 oh really you might
be right i don't know but so women
reproduce like like most of them for
most women like reproduction is
it's not it's like not even a thing that
can't happen for them what does that
mean does that mean that the 40 of men
are reproducing with the
sorry with the 99 of women yeah so
generally speak like
only 30 to 40 of men like father
almost all the children historically
so polygamy is a thing then it's always
been a thing yeah that's so you know how
we're saying what's happening now is
it's going back to what the way it works
it's interesting but but what the reason
i'm raising that is because you know
you're saying so most men don't
reproduce
historically historically
so imagine how many people are having
sex with their cousins and like
long-distance cousins and they don't
even know no but it's like okay
but i think but think of it this way
right if
let's say one word let's say a woman can
only bear the children of one man
right right
if a man has kids with four different
women
that's four different guys that will
never have kids
do you see what i'm saying ah yeah yeah
if if
because if you say because you should
have left them for another guy sperm is
cheap
eggs are valuable if a woman gets
pregnant she can't get pregnant for nine
months
and especially because we know
instinctually women would rather share
the top guy
sexually
than have the bottom guy to herself
back then like i said there wasn't birth
control so if she got pregnant yeah she
was tied to that guy forever yeah yeah
she got his child
but the reason the main the original
reason why i was raising that point
about
you know in terms of who's reproduced in
in the past is because it's something
new today men have always had to fight
for women as in to get access to women
they've always had to fire because
there's no guarantee that they'll worry
yeah there's no they'll get their genes
into the next generation so this whole
kind of simple behavior or not just
simply but guys wanting to yeah for
women it's very natural in us because we
have to fight for our genes to make it
especially when you're
told
by women this is what if you want to get
if you want to get it yeah that's what
you do yeah
live
this is what you do and so like i said
this on the last show like
women
told guys what they want
guys became those guys
and now women don't want those guys yeah
they're well
i also think men are more
feminized a little bit yeah partially
partially because i thought i was gay
yeah unless you first met me
she thought you were gay yeah she
questioned if i was gay i said that
because is that because you're an actor
yeah i mean i'm a creative person so
that's quite you know feminine qualities
and creative openness and stuff like
that you know what i mean i think this
is your world spot
maybe i don't know maybe but also as
well like i was like one of the only
guys who didn't hit on her she was and
she was like he must be gay
maybe it was that so i was right i'm
saying i'm saying that maybe
some girls i'm like have you never been
humbled maybe it's because i grew up
between two boys i've been humbled a
time or two
i don't just assume every guy i meet
like wants to sleep with me you know
what i mean yeah but if you think if you
think for every 100 guys who want to
sleep with you only one doesn't
huh i don't get it so like so you may
meet one guy who doesn't want to sleep
with you
but for every one guy who doesn't
there's probably a hundred there's 99
that will do you know what i mean yeah
so then
that one that's not that's not a very
humbling time yeah that gives you so
much gas
i'm trying to recruit girls to come on
this show i feel you
like that gives me so much gas boy i
think they've got different i think
i think it's
it's harder for men to get women
but it's
incredibly difficult for women to keep
the men that they want it's easy for
women to get a guy
yeah not to keep him though not to keep
them the ones the ones
a woman just being a woman can get a guy
oh yeah she says the right thing i'll be
like what me okay
okay like but yeah yeah a guy
yeah he has to work to get a woman i
think it was easier for women to keep
the man that they wanted
historically
the man the guy who used their first
troops yeah yeah it was easier to keep
him back then now it's now it's not now
she's got to share him in it yeah well
because
it's hard to turn down as a guy
if you could sleep with 20 girls at the
same time or be strapped down with one
girl i can't
yeah where are most guys gonna be yeah
i'll be honest it was
maybe i don't know if i should say this
depending who's watching it [ __ ] it
when my ex broke up
and i'm you know like i said very honest
like i'm like this is where i'm at do
you want to leave it
i'll be honest there was a point where
you know a two-year relationship just
came out i was seeing six seven goals at
the same time i'll be honest and they
all knew they were new
but then it got to a point seven
where yeah it was two times like it took
away from my work of course that's
assuming like it's not worth it yeah
it's not worth it six how would you
juggle what's the hell did you do that
bro what was your conversations like the
most i've done was three like seven
where did your conversation where did
you meet how often okay i got questions
okay
how often did you see them and where
would you meet them would it be dating
apps or just in person uh both so most
people most people i've dated because in
my industry like i'm meeting new people
all the time right all the time because
i'm working on set then i'm in rehearsal
and you're meeting new circles of people
all the time
um so
half i'd say was from that and then
honestly in the last
since coming out of that like that's the
most i've ever used dating apps
how often because i'm thinking
like did they get annoyed because you
can't respond to them all the time
because clearly you're hanging out with
them too right i just got questions it
was it's what was a day in your life
like when you were juggling you see one
at 12 and then until five and then the
next one came around at six you know
that didn't make something on the scene
loads of girls names
i think it was
i'm spinning the beans but you know i'll
be honest you know i'm an open book um
i'll probably see
them like
once every couple of weeks
and because i was only available once
every couple of weeks to them it's like
oh his time is very i don't get that
much time with him so when he's free i
have to see him
oh yeah okay and how did you do that how
did you how did you um
there was one or two girls that i was
honest i was like look i'm not really
looking for any serious and they're like
oh i am that this isn't gonna work cool
so everybody knew what the deal was
right like i would never lie like that
but i'm just saying it how it is you see
if it was a wednesday
and then and you knew your wednesdays
was free
i'm feeling like yo i need to go see one
of my links whatever yeah
and let's say all seven of them was free
which one do you go to yeah do you have
like a favorite did you have like a
favorite
favorite
i just got questions
i've heard three four girl rotations not
seven yes you're a different breed
it's not sustainable it's not like
there's seven days in a week
what made them stay what was you giving
them besides
you know what was she giving them
you must have been giving them something
i don't know um i'm a very
uh
generous lover generous oh okay okay
fixing the pipes
yeah i'm uh i'm very giving i don't know
maybe yeah so is that are you saying
that's what made them stay
ah
no but i think i think um i gent like
anyone who i get involved with even if
it's in a casual thing i enjoy spending
time with them that's important to me so
like i said i wouldn't just do that with
anyone yeah but what does that lack on
your finances
not much now really
today
because you'd only invite them over
lately
if you said you've got limited time
if i take a girl in a day i keep i
always keep the first date no investment
so it'll be like for a coffee
anyways i get that and mainly because
well first off mainly because she could
be one of those girls who just trying to
get a female but also as well i want to
keep at low stakes so we both feel quite
chilled because that's when you get to
know someone yeah that's very true so as
opposed to just go to this fancy
restaurant
so i always kind of
and then if that goes really well then
i'll take them out on a proper date be
like oh let's go bowling then have
dinner and then have drinks
but by that point i've already connected
with them to some degree i think first
dates are
underrated
like i think your first date can
actually give you
um
a good sense of who the person is i
think when people do like the whole
expensive restaurant on a first date is
that you
you're not focusing
on the person it's like you're focusing
on the environment oh my god you took me
here oh it's amazing yeah is that true
if you i think i think first date should
all
always be more intimate no i actually
prefer
um like a coffee or
i don't drink but i'll get a pop you
know yeah
um but because
if you're crazy i want to be able to
leave okay if i have to do a whole
dinner i'm like this could go south i
don't want to be stuck here
sitting in silence and
also i don't know i'm
i'm kind of busy so it's like that just
is a lot of time yeah i know it's so
true like my first day i always like if
it's in the summer
i like to go for a park i like to go to
the picnic i'll do a picnic oh yeah be
in the park and move to sit there a
picnic that's cute
i love i love nature yeah i mean like i
literally love sitting in down on the
grass and just having conversation yeah
and that's what i was talking like what
do i want
like i want someone who i know who i can
engage with yeah mentally yeah i don't
know that if i'm just like oh her dress
is great or we're in this fancy
restaurant yeah i don't really know i'm
not getting to know you i want to know
if you can talk yeah yeah because it
doesn't do anything for yourself yes
that doesn't do anything at all it's
just it's just it's just uh
um what's that word
um not material it is materialistic
shadow superficial hello superstitious
official yeah superficial yeah you're
just looking and like for instance what
did you say paul said she turned her
her phone to black and white because our
what did you say oh yeah i did black and
white mode on my phone because the the
colors make your brain addicted to it
yes yeah
really yeah you can you can turn off the
colors it's kind of annoying i'm
debating if i'll keep it but yeah so
like obviously usually humans human
beings brains are attracted to those
things yeah so it's like
when you actually feed in your soul
rather than what you see in your eyes
it's completely different yeah yeah
exactly different yeah
because you're already on the date
because you find them attractive yeah
that's one point
yeah
just a low stakes thing it was to be
like okay do we actually vibe as people
yeah hundred percent i prefer that was
kind of first date also i'll be honest
if i take a girl after dinner she
doesn't
i'll always pay but she doesn't offer i
won't take her out again really no i
don't like that i went on a date it's so
funny i went on a date like in the last
six months right really good girl
attractive girl having a great time went
to eat
but she was a very high earner right so
she's used to
spending
right so um the bill came
and i looked at the bill i was like all
right cool so i did this literally i
went to go and get my wallet out of my
of my
uh
my coat
and she took her phone
because the guy came over with the um
what the hell are you doing
she was like oh um i'm sorry i just want
i said don't ever in your life do that
so you so that ah that pissed me the
[ __ ] you really hate that
that pissed me off yeah don't try and
emasculate me on trying to masculine
[Music]
wouldn't you want your daughter to be
um
independent rather than
relying on a man
um
i mean yeah but you're on a date
and if i'm taking you on a date i'm
taking you on a date
don't let me take you on a date and then
try and pay for the day what do you
think i'm afraid what did you take me
for like i think i think you're 22 yeah
yeah i think this is a generational
thing maybe i'm 40. so i'm just like
don't take because my dad
don't take the piss out that's the same
like he's like why would i let a woman
pay for me
on the first date but what is that is
that uh i'm a man don't pay for me or is
that a you're a woman you shouldn't pay
it's never it's if i if i'm taking you
on a date i'm taking you on a date that
means i am paying that i just mean i'm
i'm taking okay are you talking to me on
a date yeah yeah okay okay okay by all
means
circles
[Music]
you know what's interesting if a guy
like i actually i've split on dates
before um the first day
yeah actually
mostly like one time it was just the way
like you ordered the food and i was like
whatever it's like it wasn't but
but if a guy didn't offer to pay i used
to always assume he just wasn't like
into me because i'm like a victoria's
secret model was here like you would pay
for her it's so interesting but but then
i kind of understood a little bit more
how men think like more like watching
this stuff and i didn't realize how many
guys get abused for food dates yeah i
don't know i probably wouldn't really
hold it against the guy i think
i always think that if
if a guy asks a girl out and go on a
date if he doesn't pay
then i don't think he was raised right
but if she doesn't offer to pay then i
don't think she was raised right the
matthew hussey quote
that's what he said and i was like
that's so [ __ ] true yeah
that is true
because it's not about it's what he said
it's not about it's not about money
because
on a first date like that's
that's the nicest they're going to be
what kind of precedent does that set
i don't like first dates for the guy
spends a lot of money
and that's because i feel like if he's
spending a lot of money he expects
something right and i don't want to i
don't want to feel like i owe you yeah
and i'm like
so we can just do coffee and i've been
on coffee dates and got something
[Music]
i'm just saying yeah but there's a
difference like
some guys get entitled yeah they they
get entitled to the point they get mad
yeah i just spent all this money on you
what the hell are you doing yeah right
and and then i just prefer to avoid that
situation like i'd rather split than
just feel like i have like have to do
something i don't want to do yeah i only
do that splitting thing
in relationships
yeah i hear that yes that's the only
time i do it because yeah because i was
in a relationship for like 10 years yeah
yeah yeah listen we there was things
that we split those things that we
didn't like but that whole if you're
going to do something for me i'm with
you and you're with me so it's like it's
it's coming it's for the bloody
entertainers
literally that's the only time i do like
that splitting thing that's true in a
relationship that's the only time i did
i heard that okay i got one last
question and then we're gonna wrap up
the show
how long is too long to wait
for a girl like to sleep with her like
how long would you date a girl until
you're just like it actually depends on
the girl though if you really liked her
this is a girl you really really like
because i think i think i asked you guys
you guys wouldn't wait till you were
married for a girl right no no no no no
okay she can't even have sex does
everyone know what she's doing okay but
at some point but is she like because
usually they say sex but i don't think
they're called
or
different
they think they think oral is completely
different from sex for six months
no no nothing like none of that okay so
oh nothing yeah not like well like
nothing not even like kissing and
playing no no you could do that like
um nothing sexual nothing's sexual
kissing but no no
because because there's a line and it's
interesting because you know the church
i think this is kind of going back to
the church
because they'll tell girls that have had
sex before to wait right and sometimes
that can be bad advice
because guys are like why would i wait
you got a kid
i can visually see that you've done this
before
like why would i wait
you screwed the whole whole football
team at penn state
a year ago you were like doing all kinds
of things yeah yeah so my question i
always ask this to guys because you hear
such conflicting advice right because
you'll hear
guys say oh she doesn't sleep you with
you in three days be gone like like move
on to the next girl but then you hear
guys say
that
um it doesn't matter if they like them
but i'm like i don't think most guys
will wait till they're married
so it's just
i think i think
i think there has to be
sexual progression
so like if the first couple of dates
we don't kiss but let's say the third
day we do kiss but it's a tamed one then
the next day maybe it's a bit more
yeah i don't know maybe no tongues you
know it's like a record or something i
think if i'm for me personally if i'm
seeing sexual progression
then i'm like okay we're just going at
her pace
i'll be honest though like if i don't
even get a kiss by a third date no i'm
out
because because by that point she knows
that she's attracted to me on food
like yeah i know if you're attracted to
me or not if you're if you are attracted
to me i believe most girls today they
would at least kiss you by the third
date
but if they haven't that they're just
not attracted to you in which case what
am i doing well i'm but i'm i'm talking
sex i'm not talking kissing
how long are you to wait until sex yeah
and like you're talking as in so you're
not talking sex you mean sexual like
anything sexual yeah like anything
sexual oh my gosh oral or or sex like
either free food
i'm just gonna say after about three
months are we saying like one day a week
let's say on average well you're going
on one day a week yeah
but you're talking on the phone every
day at night
baby i love you oh
if we're going on a date a week
and we're talking all the time
two months
right
two months i think because at that point
like you're just not that into me
i would think you're just not there yeah
but then they go i think you think she's
getting different somewhere else
either raw you're not yeah yeah you're
not into me enough but some people some
people might actually be just that long
you know i'm saying that they might just
be that's very true you know what i
think girls were told three months
weren't they
apparently this one
that's steve harvey
which i tell people three months
something about the cookie and the in
the cookie jar
something like that yeah
i mean but listen i'm not gonna wait
that long
i won't lie
at this point in my life being 40 years
old i think that order
what the [ __ ] am i waiting for i got it
i think age makes a difference i think
the older people get the more they're
like let's just get to it i'll go
somewhere else my dear like don't worry
about it peace out
here's my question
can you be
intimate with other people
while you're dating this person or this
is the only person
because they're not important
extension
intimacy because there's having sex then
there's making love that's true so like
definitely you've got so you're saying
the body's involved while you're dating
this woman
you're having sex elsewhere
but are you just having so you're
waiting
what do you think comes first the
relationship or sex
what do you mean like like exclusivity
or sex in your experience if if you're
dating
yeah because because now people yeah
that's what i was you think sex comes
first nowadays sex comes back yeah
exclusively the thing is if you're
dating sorry if you're dating with like
intention
i think
the relationship should come first
before the sex yeah yeah yeah yeah if
you're dating with intent if you're if
you're intending i won't be married yeah
if i want to marry this woman yeah we're
in a relationship with a boyfriend and
girlfriend now get your clothes off
i think yeah quick question don't you
guys think that it has something to do
with what you are doing with yourself at
the time also because
you will be doing something
let's say you have a career path and
you're like you're an actor yeah
you're busy bro yeah
shanice hasn't got like you can't talk
to chinese every day because you've got
stuff to do but i mean you can
any man who likes a woman will find time
in his day to talk no no i was going to
get to death
you ain't got time to talk to her but
when you when you have free time mm-hmm
you're going to talk to sunis yeah like
because it's like bro like and that's
all you want us that's the only person
you want to speak to that's true so like
you you
these girls that you're you're
not these girls or chinese
you're gonna
you're gonna want to spend more time
with her
than
anything else when you have your free
time you're absolutely right so like
that goes into into like
how you choose i guess
and
that's a big part
when i said earlier when i kind of went
on a bit of a mad one when i came out
and i was just like it's not sustainable
because it starts to perfect my work
yeah where it's just like anyone who i
spend my free time with i i have to like
who they are as a person right
so you're absolutely right why is that
say again why is that
why do i have to like them as a person
yeah because i'm giving them my time
right and energy
and i think
every time exactly and because it's your
time and energy you realize
when it's these these
like
doesn't that force you to kind of be
more serious about just life in general
and because and how you spend your time
because it's like bro if i if i spend my
time here this was not this didn't
progress me to anywhere it didn't make
me better what i would
what i would argue is that i don't spend
time with someone um based on what the
future could be i base i spent time with
them because i was spending time with
them in the present
right yeah yeah does that mean so it's
like the most
like men versus women thing to say
that is not how we think
like he's going to be great soon yeah
that's what will it be i could make him
great i wouldn't be like oh i'm with you
today because of what we could be
tomorrow yeah yeah because tomorrow may
never come
today because today is what but then but
don't you when you get if you get into a
relationship that ain't you planning
for
two three years from now
i think i think if you get into a
serious relationship
mic
um i think if i think if you get into a
relationship or maybe at least for me
then yeah you think about those things
i think i don't plan logistically
because like i'm not looking to get
married and settle down
right now so
that's not i don't think about that if
i'm like maybe when i'm in my mid-30s
and i start seeing someone seriously and
i'm like oh okay well actually yeah how
do you know sorry 27. okay you got 10.
so
yeah
but i wouldn't
that's your question
if i can be physical with other people
then
you'll wait longer
if that was the only person
that's a oh sir that was the only person
two months max i'll be honest
max
[Music]
i don't know um
my last boyfriend i was dating before we
had sex right no no no anything
yeah no nothing we didn't do anything
until we were dating um
[Music]
that was a wholesome girl
um i'm trying
no one believes me
like that's like the first is like
yeah that whatever
um how long was it it was a little
different though because when we've met
like
um we had a lot of free time because i
was both on youtube so that was all we
did was like made content and stuff
um i think i'd known him for like two
months maybe so the first month and then
we dated a month and then yeah right
okay so what that was two months that
was that was a month of dating really it
was like oh my god it was more like a
year to be honest i sort of got
how much time because
he i like lived with him basically like
before we even slept together like oh
wow because it was but it was a weird
situation how did the night time go like
what
i'm laying next to you at night and
you're supposed to be my girl hey
that don't make no sense to me listen
i'm not in the same bed as you and that
one's going down i don't know hey what
well it was it was like a different
situation because
um he
he was he was on tick-tock
so that was how i met him and
like i literally like spent and i had
just quit my job because i thought i was
moving to london so i worked in sales
and i quit my job to come to london and
then it didn't like um my season got
cancelled
so then i ended up
a lot of free time you know
um
no i mean and he he didn't have um
he was like homeless sort of
because he was he was really wealthy but
he didn't have a millionaire no yeah
yeah like actually like actually um
because he
he like lost everything but his birth
certificate
yeah you were saying yeah so i like
helped him get
um an id because i put him on my parents
lease
right and so that's what i was saying
it's kind of a weird situation
and like i was helping him like i showed
him what airbnb's are because he was
spending he's spending so much money on
these like five-star hotels i'm like
what are you doing like these nuts don't
you know and so i showed him airbnbs and
like
yeah so my point is it was kind of a
different like situation you know
but
what happened i don't know i just went
to bed
so
he didn't try anything
you didn't think oh
and he said
something doesn't sound right though i'm
not gonna lie
no because i don't know i could sleep in
the same bed and not do anything
like yeah but can he i'm saying he's a
man yeah that's alright yeah you know
what i mean well what made me like him
was he wasn't pushy at all like that's
he always say like if you wait long
enough they'll come to you
[Music]
i did um he's a better man than me i
think there was that was
definitely not where i was
we
so she wanted to wait and i was like
yeah that's absolutely fine and stuff
but then you know you're cuddling and
stuff and your spoon yeah yeah
and it got to a point i was just like
look i have respect for you i actually
don't think you should stay anymore
because i would get
like
attractive yeah yeah and i'd like do you
know what i mean so it was kind of like
i just don't think we should put
ourselves in that season so don't you
guys think time apart is you don't like
that
did that make her think oh my god
[ __ ] this guy
well then i think it was like the
following week
yeah but i was just being like i'm just
saying
women are very interesting creatures
like that but i'm just one of those guys
like i've
i i've never cheated but the biggest
reason isn't because i've
i
resist temptation better than the next
man it's because i just don't put myself
in those situations
so i'd rather remove myself from
temptation
to handle it yeah than
flip that coin do you go into temptation
what do you mean like
like
if you're over a woman and you've got a
woman and you see another one
you just avoid the whole situation
or do you find yourself going in
flirting a little bit saying oh you know
i shouldn't done that actually
do you go into temptation uh okay so
like if i've got a girlfriend and i'm in
a room with another woman who i think is
attractive
if there's a group that's fine if it's
just us two i'll leave
i'll be honest
interesting because i'm not gonna say
like
oh that nothing would ever happen
but i'm like well if i'm attracted to
her now like who she is in the moment oh
no i
i agree with you i think it's like
situations yeah even um
i think like girls a lot of times get so
drunk and kind of put themselves in like
dangerous situations at times like i
don't know i think
if you can
say that pal
no i'm serious no because um
i i said that once that like part of the
reason i don't drink is like i i've been
in like a situation i don't want to be
in before and like i was like well why
would i keep getting drunk you know it
just makes more sense to stop drinking
but people when i said that people were
like oh no like
and i was like i'm like no it makes
sense like just don't drink yeah yeah
yeah wow
that's just how i ended it i'd say yeah
so like with the whole no sex thing i'd
be like well let's spend time together
have a lovely evening and stuff but
we're not sleeping in the same bed
that's a good that's a good
as a girl who's done [ __ ] like that
that's a good move
do you guys get attracted to people
because of what they're saying like this
is that oh yeah oh my god a sweet talker
no no no no no sweet talking okay okay
depends what she talks to you but
um
don't you guys get attracted by like
let's say a female is heavily into i
don't know
anime yeah for an example wi-fi straight
away and she's talking about oh my gosh
um attack on titan attack on titans or
naruto kakashi
was fighting naruto and then all of this
happened like
if that is alien to me she has no idea
what you guys should say i don't know
let's just say a girl's like very
interested in what she's talking about
is that like
yeah you guys hormones 100
like i said i like i like someone who's
yeah he's got stuff going on out there
yeah you know what i mean yeah i agree
so isn't that the first thing that
everybody should be looking for first
yeah like that connection like a
connection
but it's interesting because the red
pill will say men don't care what you do
like we don't we don't care what you do
yeah yeah
but then that is if you if if i'm going
to spend a prolonged period of time with
this person i care how you treat me
if i'm gonna spend a prolonged period of
time with you i need to know that i can
actually be compatible with you and have
a conversation that's just me yeah no i
agree i don't know about anyone else i'm
just like that's i need to know that we
can sit down and talk yeah yeah i think
and i also need to know that we know
when to shut the hell up as well yeah
because certain people can't be i mean
you know what certain girls think they
have to talk yeah you don't always
sometimes i can be in a room with you
and just know that your presence is
there and that and that is nothing have
you seen that patricia nielsen yes i
haven't he's like men want to be alone
but we don't want to be by ourselves
he's like we want to you we want to know
that you're
oh
somewhere
that's it that's it that's in my
ex-boyfriend used to say to me actually
yeah but you know what you know what
i've got a story for you a lot yeah this
is bad
bad so like
my ex-girlfriend yeah she's like
i didn't realize i was doing this yeah
so i like i'm not an athlete like i play
basketball so
i'm
playing basketball i had like a long uni
day so
from monday to friday and i used to go
to her house on saturday it's sunday and
then back back to uni from monday right
to friday um
that's what i used to do
that's what i used to do so
would i come there and i bring my ps4
these times i can't really do like i'm
into what i'm doing like i'm studying
uh basketball like i'm tiring myself i'm
really like indulging what i'm doing
okay so now like
i'd go to hers
i'd see her say hello have a little
conversation slap on my ps4 because i'm
like i haven't had me time in a minute
you see as soon as i like slap off that
ps4 does that be coming
come come come come come and then we'll
do what we do
now go back on the ps4
i'll hug her for a little bit and then
i'll go back into ps4 and then like
it's mad because it's like and that's
why isn't it but it's mad because she
never told me until until he like broke
up she was like she was just she
i didn't realize i was doing that
because i was just so intrigued about it
i think we hate watching
because it's like because we're
attracted to like work ethic and so i
it's like when you guys are like
ambitious and like doing shits and
watching you guys watching
yeah
i mean you can do what you like he could
do what he wants like but i'm not i'm
basketball
no no i mean i'm saying like like we're
just physically it's unattractive to us
like just the same way like if a girl's
all bummed out after a long day that's
not as attractive to you guys
i hear that you know what i mean but
it's just like when you watch a guy play
video games there's nothing that's like
do you feel like it's because um
like video
playing video games is assumed
with being a boy as opposed to a man
yeah yeah does that make sense yeah so
they haven't owned a
games console since why i'm not i don't
know what i'm not gonna like tell them
because i don't play games like but what
i could stop so when you did play games
like did you not get joy out of it yeah
that i only had one game on playstation
back in the day like location what game
was it uh metal gear solid okay okay so
what i mean that was just my game
playing
the reason why i was involved in it is
because it was yeah for real for it was
an espionage and it was something that
you had to use your mind to do and blah
blah blah like but since then i've never
had it but most games i like that no
like most multiplayer games i think it's
the call of duty
i'm not gonna lie i'm not disrespecting
robot as a man that's got [ __ ] to do i
just don't play games okay no but i'm
talking about in your downtime forget
about like when you have [ __ ] to do like
your downtime your time what do you what
do you do as down time i play golf
okay so that that's the equivalent of
like maybe like a modern guy yeah
playing video games yeah i'll take off
okay
so i've got something to do in my
downtown golf would be better than as a
girl because you're doing something
watching a guy just
oh my god
i don't like video games
[Music]
but i wouldn't do anything i just like
not like them inside i'll give you some
control right i'll give you the control
and teach you how to play and then we're
gonna have competition
i do like games let me ask you this then
what if
what if his occupation was
um
being a gamer because a lot of gamers
oh
but would you then still look at it and
be like oh my gosh she's just playing
video games would you be like oh my my
my guy
tens of thousands by the minute right
that wouldn't be that attractive to me
like right a video game or career i
don't know
it's just not
those careers are more glamorous than
you think though i'm sure
those like they play games but they go
to events like where people actually
come and watch them play like yeah these
mlg events these um there are
tournaments and everything yeah
mlg major league gaming i used to play
it when i was when i was younger um
black ops 2.
okay
it's like it's like oh you're serious
yeah i was serious you're serious
literally yeah this is over my head
because you just earn money from playing
games
like earn a rank so like there's a rank
in the world
there's bronze there's bronze silver
gold platinum then masters like
interesting that's how it people go to
these competitions
and then like
let's say sometimes at the o2s people go
to these competitions and they win a
certain amount of money and then from
that youtube from youtube and stuff yeah
um
they make good content yeah yeah other
people how to play it right you know
well
that was a whole male conversation for
you then
that's how i feel in red pill sometimes
i'm like
i know it shows this part of youtube but
i'm gonna just let the guys down
especially when they're like they're all
[ __ ]
[Music]
okay uh well thank you guys for coming
on today thanks for having us this was
fun
um if you guys want to plug your like
socials
yeah
sorry um on instagram i am the black
opinion
on instagram i am
uh on twitter as sarah garvey
on youtube as sara garvey
and on tik tok as sara garvey so yeah
that's me
uh youtube stay slick with kit on
instagram
kit is me
um on instagram blue therapy uh i'm
doing sports massages so if anybody
needs a sports massage
here i believe therapy
um okay and you guys you guys know where
to find me if you're here clearly
um okay guys don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification bell if you've watched two
of my lives and you don't subscribe
we have beef okay we have we have a
problem you know
i'm like tough so
um okay and also our sponsor today is
cooking with chris so if you guys want
to support the channel considering